Des ZDF, 2020 Ihr hört CAE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Britlaff und ich begrüße alle hier wieder zu einer neuen Ausgabe
unserer ewigen Suche nach Wahrheit und Wahrhaftigkeit.
Und ja, heute soll es mal um Deutschland gehen, dachte ich mir.
Und zwar, jetzt ist 2018,
vor 50 Jahren ging das los mit diesen sagenumwobenen 68ern, über die man immer
vielleicht nur meint viel zu wissen und die aber auch irgendwie aus der ganzen
politischen Diskussion nicht rausgehen.
Auch bei den aktuell stattfindenden Koalitionsverhandlungen ist das auch immer
wieder noch so im Hinterkopf, habe ich so den Eindruck,
naja, macht auf jeden Fall mal Sinn sich das mal genauer anzuschauen,
dachte ich mir so und habe mal den Michael Sontheimer gefragt,
ob er nicht Zeit hätte hat er jetzt, hallo Micha grüße dich, moin,
Micha, du bist Historiker kann man so sagen und Journalist, richtig,
und von daher,
und du bist auch die richtige Generation.
55 bist du geboren.
Naja, ich habe mir das auch gedacht, ich bin in ein paar Tagen 63 und war 1968 demnach 13 Jahre alt.
Ich hatte auch das Glück, ich würde schon sagen, es war Glück,
1962 mit meiner Familie nach West-Berlin gezogen worden zu sein.
Das war diese absurde Mauerstadt, wo man Senatsgulasch im Keller hortete für ein Jahr.
Der Kalte Krieg war auf dem Höhepunkt, Khrushchev-Ultimatum,
die Russen kommen, die Leute ziehen weg, verkaufen die Häuser für nichts und wieder nichts.
Und ja, dann geht plötzlich an der Freien Universität in West-Berlin.
Gehen Dinge vor, die niemand erwartet hatte und deren Ausgang auch damals überhaupt
nicht vorauszusehen waren.
Und heute aber, 50 Jahre später, denke ich.
Ja, das war so eine andere Zeit damals. In West-Berlin gab es in Niederstraße Ruinen.
Der Krieg war ja noch nicht lange vorbei.
Überall saßen noch Nazis in Amt und Würden, die auf der Erde lebten.
Die Hälfte ungefähr der Menschen, die heute auf der Erde lebten,
die ökologische Frage war weder irgendwie bekannt noch wurde sie ernst genommen.
Es war eine ganz andere Situation. Es ging damals eigentlich vielmehr noch aus
dem Schatten dieser nationalsozialistischen und dann zwangsdemokratisierten
postnationalsozialistischen deutschen Gesellschaft zu treten.
Wie muss man sich dieses Berlin vorstellen? Du hast das so ein bisschen angedeutet,
klar, die Mauer stand und ja.
Wenn du damals in West-Berlin zur Schule gegangen bist, dann hast du so Lieder
gesungen auf dem Schulhof oder auf dem Schulweg, wir hängen Mr.
Ulbricht auf dem Brandenburger Tor, wir hängen Mr. Ulbricht auf dem Brandenburger Tor.
Und Khrushchev gab es noch, das war der andere Böse und Ulbrichts KZ,
also man war so richtig auf dem Vorposten des Freien Westens in dieser Insel,
die vom bösen Kommunismus.
Umgeben war und wo die Wellen des Bösen anbrandeten und fühlte sich so als Frontstretter
im Grunde beim Sold der Armees oder irgendwie, die waren ja die eigentlichen
Chefs und also Also es war sehr surreal und sehr besonders.
Das Entscheidende war in West-Berlin, dass es keine Wehrpflicht gab und keine Sperrstunde.
Und diese beiden Tatsachen haben ungeheuer viele oder nicht ungeheuer,
aber tausende und mehr und mehr junge Männer nach West-Berlin gelockt.
Noch dazu kam, es war billig, man bekam irgendwelche, wenn man Facharbeiter
war, irgendwelche Prämien, man musste weniger Steuern bezahlen.
Denn West-Berlin war ja nicht alleine lebensfähig, bekam mehr als die Hälfte
des Geldes aus der Bundesrepublik.
Das wurde als politisches Symbol hochgehalten.
Und da kamen dann diese ganzen jungen Menschen aus Westdeutschland.
Es gab diese riesigen Wohnungen, auch ein Vakuum.
Sechs, sieben Zimmer Wohnungen in Wilmersdorf. Da saß vielleicht noch eine Wilmersdorfer Witwe drin.
Aber die Männer waren ja im Krieg geblieben. Die Bourgeoisie war,
wenn sie jüdisch war, umgebracht worden zum größten Teil, wenn sie arisch war,
nach Westdeutschern abgehauen vor den Russen.
Und dann in dieses Vakuum strömten eben Freidenken, ziemlich intelligente junge Menschen.
Die keinen Bock auf Wehrpflicht hatten.
Die keine Lust auf Wehrpflicht hatten. Und eins muss man auch sagen,
das war damals die Leute, die 68 den Aufstand geprobt haben in West-Berlin,
aber auch in München oder Hamburg und in anderen Städten in der Bundesrepublik.
Das war eine wirkliche Elite.
Es studierten damals 300.000 in der Bundesrepublik in West-Berlin, 300.000 Menschen.
Heute haben wir 4,5 Millionen. Das heißt, damals war es weniger als ein Zehntel
der Zahl, die heute Studenten sind.
Es ist auch kein Wunder, dass von den drei Gründern der Roten Armee Fraktion,
nämlich Andreas Bader, Horst Mahler und Gudrun Ensslin,
zwei von der Studienstiftung des Deutschen Volkes ein Stipendium hatten, weil sie so,
über die Maßen intelligent war, nämlich Horst Mahler und Gudrun Enzlin,
Andreas Bader war noch mehr so ein Autodieb.
Aber die beiden anderen waren, Gudrun Enzlin war eine großartige Germanistin,
Literaturwissenschaftlerin.
Das heißt, es war jetzt nicht so ein, zunächst nicht so ein Jugendaufstand,
sondern im SDS, im Sozialistischen Deutschen Studentenbund, versammelte sich
die kritische Intelligenz der Republik.
Und die fingen an nachzudenken über internationale Beziehungen und als dann,
und das war die erste größere Demonstration in West-Berlin.
Ende 1964 ein kongolesischer Ministerpräsident namens Chombe nach West-Berlin kam zum Staatsbesuch.
Der verdächtigt wurde zu Recht, mithilfe von Geheimdiensten einen Widersacher
Lumumba im Kongo umgebracht zu haben.
Als der nach Berlin kam, taten sich schwarze Studenten, afrikanische Studenten
und der SDS zusammen und machten eine Demonstration im Flughafen Tempelhof, wo der John B. ankam.
Das war die erste, vielleicht tausend Leute, die erste Demonstration,
wo sich Westberliner Studenten in irgendwelche internationalen Belange und Themen einmischten.
War aber nur der Anfang, denn im Februar 1965 gab es dann eine Demonstration
gegen den Vietnamkrieg.
Und der Vietnamkrieg war das Erweckungserlebnis, klingt so blöd religiös,
aber sozusagen das Ereignis,
was hier Tausende über Jahre auf die Straßen gebracht hat.
Also auf jeden Fall losging es Mitte der 60er Jahre, kann man sagen.
Schon vor 68. Also 68 begann im Grunde 65.
Ja. Warum macht man es eigentlich an dem Jahr so fest?
Das liegt daran, dass 68 ja kein nationales deutsches Ereignis war.
Es war hier eigen und anders als in anderen Ländern, aber eigentlich von den USA ausgehend.
Free Speech Movement in Berkeley 1965, von den USA ausgehend,
bis aber dann nach Osteuropa, rebellierende Studenten in Warschau oder in Belgrad,
Jugoslawien, kam eine Jugendbewegung gegen autoritäre Strukturen in Gang.
Im Osten natürlich gegen den stalinistischen Parteikommunismus,
im Westen gegen den Spätkapitalismus, wie es genannt wurde, oder die restaurativen,
konservativen Strukturen.
Und 1968 kam es dann in Frankreich zu dem sogenannten Paris-Amai-Generalstreik
General de Gaulle flüchtet aus dem Land da muss man sich mal vorstellen,
der französische Präsident haut ab nach Baden-Baden, weil da seine Panzer stehen,
die der französischen Besatzungstruppen und das Ganze steht so auf der Kippe
letzten Endes wählen die Franzosen dann doch die konservative Variante,
aber das war also eine große Sache und es gab emblematische Fotos von Danikon wendet.
Wie er in Paris auf den Barrikaden Reden hält und es gab dann in Osteuropa genauer
in der Tschechoslowakei in Prag im August die gewaltsame Niederschlagung des
sogenannten Prager Frühlings,
des reformkommunistischen Versuchs von Dubček und anderen,
einen freiheitlichen Sozialismus zu entwickeln gegen den stalinistisch-diktatorischen
und das führte wieder zu Soldatät im Westen, aber auch in der DDR,
zum Beispiel in Ostberlin, rannten junge Leute los, Thomas Brasch,
Bettina Wegner, verteilten Zettel, Flugblätter,
wurden dann zu Gefängnisstrafen verurteilt.
In 1968 kulminierte eben das alles.
In Deutschland war der Höhepunkt, in Anführungszeichen, eigentlich der Studentenbewegung,
waren die sogenannten Osterunruhen.
Im April 1968 schoss ein Nazi, Rudi Dutschke, an, der so als der Kopf der Studentenbewegung
in Deutschland galt und daraufhin gab es die größten Unruhen in der Bundesrepublik seit ihrer Gründung,
seit dem Krieg. Das passierte 1968.
Aber im Grunde, wenn man sich heute den politischen Verlauf dieser Bewegung
anschaute, die von einer Studentenbewegung dann sehr stark zu einer Jugendbewegung
wurde, dann kann man sagen, es ging 1967 los.
Und 1969 zerfiel es dann und löste sich auf. Aber die eigentliche Dynamik spielte
sie ab zwischen 67 und 69.
68 ist dann das Symboljahr in der Mitte.
Das ist schon mal ein ganz guter Schnelldurchlauf. Jetzt würde ich aber ganz
gerne nochmal so ein bisschen in diese Zeit einsinken, in dieses Deutschland 65.
Wir reden natürlich erstmal von zwei Deutschlands und von daher müsste man im
Prinzip sowohl in den Osten als auch in den Westen gucken.
Du bist aus dem Westen, ich bin aus dem Westen. Schwierig.
Nein, es gibt aber durchaus sehr ähnliche Dinge, die ich nun wieder von Freunden
weiß, die in Ostberlin damals aufgewachsen sind.
Zum Beispiel hat mir Bommi Baumann, der war dann später ein umherschreifender Haschgebell,
ein anarchistischer Terrorist, ist aber wieder ausgestiegen und der ging in
Lichtenberg in Ostberlin zur Schule und der hatte ein Mickey Mouse T-Shirt.
Und es wurde beim Fahnenappell verbrannt, öffentlich auf dem Schulhof, vom Lehrer.
Und mir ist zwar kein T-Shirt verbrannt worden, aber wenn du 1965 dich als Jugendlicher
auf die Stufen der Kaiser Wilhelm Gedächtniskirche am Kudamm in Westberlin gesetzt hast,
Lambrusco-Flasche, Paschisch gab es noch nicht, Gitarre, dann kamen die Bürger
da vorbei und sagten, guck mal, das sind die Gammler, sagten die zu ihren Kindern.
Und du bist in der U-Bahn beschimpft worden als Langhaariger.
Du musstest in Kreuzberg, damals nur ein richtiger Arbeiterbezirk,
du musstest wirklich aufpassen, dass du nicht Schläge gekriegt hast von irgendwelchen
Proleten, weil du lange Haare hattest.
Das heißt, es gab eine...
Gesellschaft, in der Konventionen eine ungeheure Rolle spielten und wer da ausbrach,
der hatte aber wirklich was zu erwarten.
Von daher sind die Reaktionen, wenn man sich Berlin mal anguckt,
es gab 1965 ein Konzert der Rolling Stones in der Waldbühne.
Die spielten nur vier Nummern, Publikum flippte aus, zerlegte die Waldbühne.
Da schrieb eine Bild-Zeitungsreporterin damals einen dramatischen Bericht,
dass sie die Hölle erlebt habe.
Und dieser Bericht wurde im neuen Deutschland in voller Länge abgedruckt,
weil die Kommunisten im Osten gegen die Jugendlichen, gegen die Langhaarigen,
gegen diese Affenmusik und wie es hieß, genauso Ressentiments hatten wie im Westen.
Also da, das ähnelte sich sehr.
Und wenn man so generationsmäßig auseinanderdividiert, wie es heute gerne gemacht
wird, dann waren die 68er eben die Kriegskinder.
Die hatten noch im Bombenkampf Keller mit gesessen und so, aber hatten mit den
Nazi-Verbrechen als Kinder nichts zu tun.
Aber ihre Eltern, was hat denn Papa in Russland damals gemacht?
Oder war denn in Auschwitz war das alles vollautomatisch? Hat da kein deutscher Mahn angelegt.
Also diese Fragen kamen dann in 60er Jahren auch hoch und es ging auch gegen diese.
Furchtbaren Konventionen. Papa hat in der Familie das sagen,
Kinder haben die Schnauze zu halten, Frauen auch zu kuschen,
also gegen diese im Grunde faschistische Gesellschaft, die zwangsdemokratisiert
wurde durch die westlichen Alliierten oder,
zwangssozialisiert worden durch die russischen Besatzer, aber im Grunde eine
hohle, zerstörte Gesellschaft,
die sich an diesen Formen festhielt und das bedeutete eben, man konnte doch
damals, dass ein junges Paar konnte, wenn sie nicht verheiratet waren,
in einer Pension oder im Hotel überhaupt kein Zimmer mieten.
Frauen mussten die Genehmigung ihrer Männer haben, wenn sie arbeiten wollten.
Also ich meine, so eine Gesellschaft war das. Und von daher war es eigentlich
für junge, klar denkende, vielleicht auch gebildete Menschen,
nahezu zwangsläufig sich gegen bestimmte Sachen aufzulehnen,
überhaupt Sachen in Frage zu stellen. Darum geht es eigentlich in 60er Jahren.
Nicht alles hinzunehmen, sondern warum ist das denn so? Muss das so sein?
Kann es nicht anders sein? Kann es nicht besser sein? Nachdenken, Theorie.
Ja und vor allem, es wird ja auch vorher schon aufgeschlossene Menschen gegeben
haben, aber die sind natürlich in der Nazizeit einfach komplett untergegangen
oder eben auch vielleicht mit vernichtet worden.
Ja, ja, ja. Nein, es gab so diese, das ist ja das Traurige an Deutschland, dass...
Nazi-Deutschland, die Juden umgebracht oder vertrieben hat, die in der Kultur
und der ganzen Gesellschaft eine wichtige Bedeutung auch gespielt haben und
die linken Intellektuellen ins Exil getrieben hat.
Naja und es blieben halt dann die Leute, die in inneren Widerstand gingen,
so passive Mitläufer, die nur so dann auch überlebt haben und das fehlte sozusagen.
Also Deutschland ist ja auch kulturell geplündert worden,
entweder durch die aktive Ermordung und Vernichtung der Juden und Andersdenkender,
als auch der Leute, die sie nicht bekommen haben, die dann aber einfach in die
USA und andere Länder, Frankreich, England, geflohen sind.
Wobei man sagen muss, es gibt so einen Mythos inzwischen.
68 ist ja schwer als das zu betrachten, was es wirklich war.
Es ist dieser überstrahlende Mythos. Ein wichtiges Moment dieses Mythos ist,
die 68er haben die Deutschen dazu gezwungen, sich mit ihrer Nazi-Vergangenheit auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich meine, was richtig ist, es wurde in Berlin 1967 ein Mann,
der Kammerrichter Rehse,
der bei Freisler am Volksgerichtshof in Nazi-Deutschland die 200 noch was Todesurteile
unterzeichnet hatte, wurde in Westberlin freigesprochen.
Ja, der war angeklagt.
Es wurde ja kein Nazirechter jemals wegen seiner Urteile, auch wenn es Todesurteile
waren, überhaupt angeklagt.
Und dagegen demonstrierten natürlich die Studenten und sonst niemand.
Das regte sonst entweder nicht auf, aber auf jeden Fall kamen die Leute nicht auf die Straße.
Aber es war nicht so wichtig. Also die Auseinandersetzung mit der Nazi-Vergangenheit
hat auch die Studenten damals überfordert.
Rudi Dutschke hat mal gesagt, wenn wir uns damit auch noch beschäftigen,
dann kommen wir ja mit unserer Revolution nie richtig voran.
Also es waren andere Dinge damals wichtiger und vor allen Dingen auch dieser
internationale Kontext, den ich erwähnt habe. der Vietnamkrieg und der Kampf
der Völker der dritten Welt um die Befreiung von den Kolonialregimes.
Wobei ich frage mich halt, welche Rolle dieses Internationale in dem Fall eigentlich
wirklich gespielt hat, weil das Kernproblem war ja erstmal vor der Tür und man
muss sich auch immer wieder klar machen, dass,
Diese total vernetzte Welt, über die man so viel weiß, die gab es damals einfach noch nicht.
Internationale Wahrnehmung, es gab halt ein wenig Fernsehen, die andere waren da.
Das würde ich nicht unterschätzen. Der Vietnamkrieg wurde in den 60er Jahren
in einer Art und Weise im Fernsehen dargestellt, wie kein Krieg seitdem mehr.
Du hast wirklich gesehen, wie amerikanische Tubschrauber mit Napalmdörfer auslöschen.
Jeden Abend, Tagesschau, 20 Uhr.
Hast du diese Bilder gesehen? Es gab damals noch nicht dieses Konzept des Embedded
Journalismus, sondern die sind ziemlich frei, konnten sich da bewegen,
wenn sie Beziehungen hatten.
Und da wurde das Bild eines schaurigen und ja auch politisch nicht wirklich
zu rechtfertigenden Krieges wurde gezeigt und ganz viele,
also Gudrun Ensslin später Rote Armee Fraktion wurden daran irre,
dass die Deutschen, die Westdeutschen inzwischen Wirtschaftswunder,
so ganz zufrieden, saturiert da vorm Fernseher saßen und das zur Kenntnis nahmen, aber nichts taten.
Obwohl sie selber so eine Schuldgeneration sind.
Naja, ja und vor allen Dingen auch, weil die Amerikaner waren doch unsere Freunde,
die garantierten die Freiheit von West-Berlin oder der Bundesrepublik und dann
machen sie sowas und das kann man doch nicht einfach hinnehmen und schlagen.
Weihnachten, das war 1967, sind ein paar Studenten in die Kaiser Wilhelm Gedächtniskirche
zum Weihnachtsgottesdienst gegangen abends und hatten Schilder dabei von gefolterten
Vietnamesen und die sind rausgeprügelt worden von den Christen aus der Kirche.
Der Rudi Dutschke hat so einen ehemaligen SA-Harmann mit der Krücke über den
Kopf gezogen, dass er ins Krankenhaus musste und sich nähen lassen.
Also die Ablehnung und die Hysterie, auf der damals die wirklich wenigen,
es waren ja wenige, diese acht Sätze gestoßen sind, das war schon heftig.
Und hat natürlich dann einen selbst auch darin bestärkt, dass man richtig ist, denn wenn,
man nur in West-Berlin demonstrieren musste und an jeder Ecke standen irgendwelche
Penner aus der Eckkneipe und sagten, ja mal arbeiten oder irgendwie ab nach
drüben und so ich hat Adolf vergessen und nur diese Sprüche,
aber endlos bei jeder Demonstration,
dann wundert man sich doch auch ein bisschen darüber was das für eine Gesellschaft
ist und ob man da nicht ein bisschen was verbessern könnte.
Ja.
Warum war denn das so extrem, die Reaktion darauf?
War das so die Angst davor, jetzt auch noch mit in Schuld gezogen zu werden
oder seine Schuld anerkennen zu müssen? War das so die Angst davor?
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass es so sehr um die Auseinandersetzung mit Nationalsozialismus ging.
Was haben die Eltern damals getan? Sondern es ging eigentlich mehr so darum
um Demokratisierung, um Freiheit, um Gleichheit, um die Werte der französischen Revolution.
Dass junge Leute gesagt haben, wir wollen uns nicht immer von irgendwelchen
Greisen da sagen lassen, was zu machen.
Wir wollen keinen Bundeskanzler Kurt-Georg Kiesinger haben, der NSDAP-Mitglied war.
Wir wollen lieber einen Willy Brandt haben, der im Widerstand war,
der dann auch kam. Das heißt, es ging mehr um,
Demokratisierung und Gerechtigkeit und neben diesem großen Thema Vietnam war
am Anfang eigentlich auch die Reform der Universitäten das große Thema.
Es gibt diesen bekannten Spruch, unter den Talaren der Muff von tausend Jahren.
Damals sind ja wirklich die Professoren noch mit so albernen Hütchen und so
samtenden Talaren einmarschiert, also ein bisschen karnevalsmäßig und ja,
oder heute ist es ja auch wieder beliebt, kommt ja aus Amerika alles zurück.
Und das fanden die Studenten, die wollten mitbestimmen an den Hochschulen.
Sie wollten auch mit darüber reden, was da gelehrt ist und was sie lernen wollen.
Und das war ein wesentlicher Ansatzpunkt und da ging es natürlich darum,
irgendwelche althergebrachten Mummenschanz, irgendwelche Zeremonielle,
die völlig aus der Zeit gefallen waren, die zu überwinden.
Im Grunde ging es in vielem eigentlich nur darum, um eine Modernisierung und
Reformierung der Bundesgesellschaft.
Es ging nicht gleich sofort um die Weltrevolution und den Sieg im Volkskrieg überall.
Okay, das meinte ich ja auch so. Also Vietnamkrieg ist vielleicht insofern auch ein Novum gewesen,
weil auf einmal so ein globales Thema medial perzeptiert wurde,
was neu war, weil es möglich war, weil es Fernsehen eine gewisse Verbreitung
gefunden hat, weil der Krieg stattfand, weil auch so über ihn berichtet wurde,
der ja im Prinzip auch so als,
der Grund, glaube ich, für den militärischen, für die Niederlage letzten Endes
der Amerikaner gewertet wurde, dass sie diesen Krieg medial verloren haben.
Ja, das ist völlig richtig. Es gab natürlich Aufstände und Demonstrationen gegen
den Vietnamkrieg in ganz vielen Ländern.
Letzten Endes ist er natürlich im eigenen Land verloren worden,
weil auch die Mehrheit der Amerikaner wollte da nicht sterben.
Damals war noch Wehrpflicht in den USA.
Die jungen Weißen wollten nicht sterben. Die haben dann die Schwarzen bezahlt,
um da in Vietnam zu sterben, so sukzessive.
Aber es war so, dass das nicht rechtfertigt. Die Amerikaner haben nicht eingesehen,
wozu sollen wir hier 50.000, 60.000 junge Amerikaner opfern,
weil angeblich sonst die Chinesen da oder die Russen da irgendwo, JWD irgendwas machen.
Ich will aber noch einen Punkt sagen zu dem Globalen damals.
Das andere Globale war die Popmusik, die damals noch nicht Popmusik genannt wurde.
Aber natürlich haben junge Leute 1965 in der Bundesrepublik Bob Dylan gehört
und seine ersten politischen, pazifistischen Songs gehört.
Oder sie haben dann 1968 die Rolling Stones gehört, Street Fighting Man.
Also es gab in Filmen auch eine gewisse Erneuerung oder es gab neue Filmemacher.
Also diese kulturelle Komponente war immer auch international und sehr stark
von den USA übrigens beeinflusst,
weshalb mich persönlich der Vorwurf, ich sei anti-amerikanisch,
weil ich zum Beispiel dagegen bin, wenn die USA mal schnell in den Irak gehen
und da Chaos hinterlassen,
wird einem ja gesagt, man sei anti-amerikanisch.
Ich bin zutiefst geprägt durch die amerikanische Literatur, durch die Beatniks,
die wurden damals gelesen, Allen Ginsberg, Jack Kerak wurde gelesen und die amerikanische Musik.
Und,
Neben dieser, ich kann gar nicht sagen, was stärker ist, es gab diese internationale Strömung.
Es fuhren ja auch Leute dann vom SDS aus Deutschland mal in die USA und da gab
es ein SDS und guckten sich an, was wurde da gemacht.
Oder dann die Konvente aus Frankreich ausgewiesen, landete dann in Frankfurt,
mischte sich da bei den Linksradikalen ein.
Also es gab eine internationale Komponente, es war im Vergleich zu heute mit
der Kommunikationsstruktur des Internets,
war es noch vergleichsweise harmlos und sozusagen nach einzelnen Ländern dann
aufgeteilt, Aber es gab ja diese Vorstellung von internationaler Solidarität,
dass also Jugendliche oder Studenten oder Menschen in der Bundesrepublik,
aber genauso in Frankreich und genauso in Jugoslawien gegen den Krieg in Vietnam sein können.
Und also diese beiden Momente,
nationale Entwicklung, spezielle Entwicklung in Deutschland mit Nazi-Deutschland
in der Vergangenheit und diese internationale Ebene, die mischten sich so durcheinander,
waren beide eigentlich gleich wichtig.
Also eine globale kulturelle Entwicklung, vielleicht auch Revolution,
immer schwieriges Wort, aber auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine es ganz einfach. Eine Revolution, da
reicht es nicht wenn ein paar tausend mal einen
Aufstand proben eine sehr finde ich
nach wie vor gute Parole die ich auch selbst
damals mitgerufen habe war wir sind eine kleine radikale Minderheit und das
war absolut realistisch denn ich habe gesagt es gab damals nur 300.000 Studenten
im Vergleich zu 4,5 Millionen heute Und wenn beim Vietnamkongress,
ziemlich genau vor 50 Jahren,
im Februar 1968,
versammelten sich ein paar tausend Menschen,
Links-Radikale aus verschiedenen Ländern, in der TU, in West-Berlin und zu einem
großen Soldatitätskongress.
Es gab eine Demo am Tag danach und da liefen nach sehr großzügigen Schätzungen
maximal 10.000 Leute mit.
Das war eigentlich nicht viel. später.
Aber für damit die Verhältnisse waren es viel.
Ja, war es ziemlich viel. Als dann der Berliner Senat allerdings zur Gegendemonstration
aufrief und der öffentliche Dienst frei bekam und die dann dutschgedoppelt Gänger
jagten und fast umbrachten paar Tage nach dieser,
Demonstration der 10.000,
vom Vietnamkongress da kamen über 100.000 auf die Straße.
Also es war eine kleine radikale Minderheit und Und später, wenn man sich anguckt,
Demonstrationen gegen die Atomkraftwerke,
gegen Stationierung von Pershing, Friedensbewegung oder auch in West-Berlin
dann Hausbesitzerbewegung auf Amplätze 15.000, 20.000 auf der Straße.
Also 68 war in keiner Weise eine Revolution.
Es war eine Rebellion oder eine Revolte, wo aber den Beteiligten klar war,
dass sie keine Chance haben, sich wirklich so durchzusetzen,
dass man sagen könnte, sie hätten gewonnen.
Aber man hat trotzdem.
Naja, es gibt ja Situationen, wo einem Dinge so absurd vorkommen oder wo man
dann Dinge so unmoralisch findet, dass man sagt,
also selbst wenn wir jetzt damit nicht durchkommen, müssen wir wenigstens sagen,
so geht es nicht. Oder wir waren nicht dabei.
Und das war also beim Vietnamkrieg immerhin noch so, der kam ja dann zum Ende
und die Amerikaner haben sich zurückgezogen und haben im Grunde verloren.
Aber jetzt die Bundesrepublik zum Beispiel in eine sozialistische,
freie Gesellschaft schnell mal zu verwandeln, da haben wohl die allermeisten
damals gesehen, das ist unrealistisch.
Da kommen wir nicht durch, da haben wir keine Chance.
Also,
Nochmal die Gesamtmengelage so ein bisschen zusammenzufassen.
Es gab halt die Situation in Deutschland,
ausgelöst durch den Krieg und einfach den Mangel an kulturell wichtigen Personen,
die einfach dieser Gesellschaft abhandengekommen sind über einen Zeitraum von
mindestens einem, wenn nicht mehr Jahrzehnt.
Es gab diesen globalen kulturellen Wechsel, die mediale Präsenz,
den Widerstand konkret gegen den Vietnamkrieg,
Musik, einfach Hippie-Bewegung kann man ja den Atemzug wahrscheinlich auch noch
nennen die sich dann halt parallel in den USA entwickelte,
Drogenkonsum hat glaube ich auch auf einmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung erhalten,
Womit fing es dann an?
Ganz einfach, es setzte dann eine politische Dynamik ein, die keiner so gewollt
hatte und hinter dem Rücken aller Akteure,
als der Schar von Persien 1967 am 2.
Juni als Staatsbesucher nach West-Berlin kam und hier mit allen Ebenen,
Ehren eines Staatsbesuchs roter Teppich, Spalier, Tralala empfangen wurde,
da mobilisierten Studenten.
Gegen diesen Besuch, weil sie sagten, der Schar lässt zu Hause Oppositionelle foltern.
Das ist ein Land, wo einige wenige unglaublich reich sind wie er.
Also es gab einfach eine Kritik daran, dass die Bundesrepublik einen solchen
Mann mit diesen Ehren empfing.
Und bei der Demonstration am Abend vor der Oper,
in der der Schaden mit seiner Frau und dem regierenden Bürgermeister und anderen
Hochwürdigkeiten die Zauberflöte von Mozart bakutieren konnte,
wurde ein junger Student,
Benno Ohnesorg, der Name ist relativ geläufig, von ihm selber ist nicht so viel bekannt.
Er war ein interessierter, aufgeschlossener, aber jetzt nicht radikaler, junger Student.
Der wurde erschossen von einem Kriminalpolizisten in Zivil namens Coraz.
Und dann verstanden die Studenten, die da demonstriert hatten,
auch Leute wie Otto Schidi, der später auch SPD-Innenminister wurde,
oder Christian Ströbele, der später Abgeordneter Grund wurde,
die verstanden am nächsten Morgen die Welt nicht mehr, weil die Springerpresse,
die in Berlin 70 Prozent, in Westberlin 70 Prozent des Marktes Bärsche,
die Studenten für den Tod ihres eigenen Mannes sozusagen verantwortlich machten.
Der Bürgermeister von Berlin, Heinrich Alberts, der ist dann weniger als ein
Jahr später zurückgetreten, auch wegen dieser,
sagte, die Geduld der Stadt ist am Ende der Terror der Studenten und die Studenten
saßen verängstigt irgendwo in der FU in Dahlem.
Es gab ein Demonstrationsverbot und wussten nicht, was ihnen geschieht und merkten,
dass diese permanente Hetze, also muss man,
Kann ich mich noch gut erinnern als Westberliner, die Springer-Zeitung,
da war die BZ ganz hervorragend,
die zeigten dann immer Studenten mit dunklen Bärten, so rutschgeartig und mit
Keulen, die dann immer irgendwelche braven Westberliner mit ihren Keulen verfolgten.
Also es war so, dass Studenten damals wirklich Angst hatten,
teilweise auf die Straße zu gehen, weil sie sagten, da ist der Mob draußen.
Weil man schon als Student so erkannt wurde.
Ja, na gut, die hatten dann, sie sahen unglaublich ordentlich.
Also wenn man sich die Bilder von 68 und 68 ansieht, die hatten ja noch Schlips und so.
Und wie gesagt, die kommen in der Elite und hatten noch nicht so besonders lange Haare.
Aber das reichte schon, wenn sie ein bisschen länger wurden, die Haare.
Und es gab wirklich so eine Pogromstimmung. Und damit kamen die Studenten nicht klar.
Ich habe später, das fand ich sehr interessant, mit einer Frau gesprochen,
einer Studentin von damals, die bei dieser Demonstration an der Oper dabei war, gegen den Schar.
Und die dann zufällig, da so ein Mann in einem roten Hemd reglos auf dem Boden liegen sah, hinlief.
Sie wusste nicht, dass es Benno ohne Sorge ist, aber er war das.
Der war tödlich getroffen.
Und sie kniete sich dann so hin und legte ihre Tasche unter seinen Kopf und
versuchte, den irgendwie so da besser hinzulegen. und.
Die hat mir dann später gesagt, das war so ein Schock,
dass also in ihren Armen ein völlig unschuldiger Student, der von einem irren
Waffennarren und Kriminalpolizisten ermordet worden war, in ihren Händen sozusagen starb,
dass sie sich auf eine Art und Weise radikalisiert hat, die ihr so von ihrem
Naturellen und auch von ihrer liberalen Familie überhaupt nicht entsprochen hat.
Die wurde dann Maoist, den Sieg im Volkskrieg, Mao Zittung und ist dann irgendwann
auch wieder davon abgekommen.
Aber die sagte, also diese Reaktion und dass auf uns geschossen wurde und dass
einer starb und wir die Schuld dafür zugeschoben bekamen,
die hat sie in einer Art und Weise radikalisiert, wie sie es selber nie gewollt hat.
Und es waren ja nicht die einzigen Schüsse.
Dann weniger als ein Jahr später, im April 1968, schoss dieser Rechtsradikale,
der aus München kam, auf Rudi Dutschke.
Und Rudi Dutschke wurde wirklich von den meisten SDS-Leuten geliebt,
weil er so die Reinheit des Revolutionärs hatte und mit allen redete und so
besessen war und auch auf eine merkwürdige,
sehr schwer verständliche Art aber toll reden konnte. und der wird angeschossen.
Und da fühlten die Studenten irgendwie, der meinte uns, uns alle,
die wollen uns umbringen hier.
Und das sind die Leute, so hat Skudron
Enzli mal dann bei einem Treffen im SDS-Zentrum nach am Abend des 2.
Juni 67 gesagt, das ist die Generation mit Auschwitz, mit denen kann man nicht
reden, die bringen uns alle um, lasst
uns bewaffnen, wir gehen zu den Polizeikasernen und holen uns Waffen.
Die haben es zum Glück nicht gemacht, aber es.
Diese kleine Gruppe sah sich nicht nur Kritik oder dass man irgendwie angemault
wurde oder von der Schule geworfen wurde, weil man zu lange Haare hatte,
gab es ja auch alles, sondern die schießen auf uns, die wollen uns umbringen.
Und das war natürlich dann ein Schock, der einmal zu so einer Radikalisierung
geführt hat und auch letzten Endes, aber darüber sollten wir jetzt noch nicht sprechen,
dann in den 70er Jahren dazu geführt hat, dass eine Gruppe namens Rote Armee
Fraktion losgegangen ist und sich
auch bewaffnet hat und dann einen terroristischen Kampf angefangen hat.
Wann hat sich denn dieser SDS gebildet und warum?
Der hat sich schon sehr früh gebildet oder gegründet und zwar ist der so als
sozialistischer deutscher Studentenbund.
So heißt das ja.
Und der ist schon kurz nach der Gründung der Bundesrepublik ist der,
als der SPD nahestehend gegründet von Helmut Schmidt, der spätere Bundeskanzler
war mal Vorsitzender von dem Verein, aber wie das immer so ist bei Studenten,
die neigen dann noch so zu linken, radikalen,
Vorstellungen und die SPD ja immer weniger und deshalb wurde der der ist dann
Anfang der 60er Jahre komplett ausgeschlossen und aus der SPD.
Und führte dann so ein, nicht mal Büro, sondern so ein bescheidenes Leben,
an den Universitäten und das hat sich dann verändert, erst so Mitte der 60er
Jahre da kamen dann Leute wie,
Rudi Dutschke, Bernd Rabel übrigens beides Flüchtlinge aus dem Osten die aus
der DDR abgehauen waren weil es ihnen da,
zu diktatorisch war Aber die kamen dann in den SDS und der wurde dann nach dem 2.
Juni 67, wurde der zur bestimmenden Organisation.
Da traten dann viele ein und es war so, dass dann die beiden wichtigsten Zentren waren.
Das SDS war einmal Frankfurt, da saßen so mehr die Theoretiker,
die hatten dann schon bei Adorno irgendwie hochkomplexe Theorien sich da einverleibt
und da war dann Jürgen Habermas und Max Horkheimer von der Frankfurter Schule,
das war so mehr die Theorieabteilung.
Die Westberliner waren immer so ein bisschen pragmatischer und mehr so auf Handlungen,
auch auf politisches Handeln orientiert und nicht nur auf die großen komplexen Gedanken.
Und ja, der SDS blieb eigentlich bis zum Schluss, der hat sich 1969 dann selbst aufgelöst,
war eher sozusagen die bestimmende Organisation der Studenten,
da wurden die Debatten geführt,
da gab es Delegiertenkonferenzen, dann schickten also alle Abteilungen aus allen
Städten, erschickten dann ihre Leute dahin und da wurde dann sehr kontrovers dann immer debattiert.
Das heißt, Dutschke hat sich dem angeschlossen, aber eigentlich erst durch Leute
wie Dutschke hat dieser SDS so eine Wendung genommen und wurde dann zur Sammlungsbewegung der 68er.
Ja, richtig.
Aber er hat das jetzt nicht wirklich angeführt.
Da offiziell hatte Dutsch gewusst nicht, dass er jemals einen Posten hatte im SDS.
Er war einfach derjenige, der auf der Straße, wenn es irgendeine Konfrontation
mit der Polizei gab, sich das Megafon geschnappt hat und dann Reden gehalten hat.
Oder der dann auch…,
Bei öffentlichen Diskussionen mit anderen bekannten Menschen,
also der regierende Bürgermeister Klaus Schütz, SPD.
Der ist dann mal ins Audimax gekommen Ende 1967 und hat da mit den Studenten
diskutiert, ging da ziemlich unter und da war Rudi Dutschke dann der wichtigste
Redner für die Studenten.
Als der Mann, der für die Studentenwähling eigentlich intellektuell am wichtigsten war, Herbert Marcuse,
ein jüdischer Philosoph, in Berlin geboren, 1918 schon bei der Ritterrepublik
als Schüler im Schülerrat dabei gewesen, dann emigriert.
Und als der nach Berlin zurückkam und seine Theorien hervorgestellt hat,
des Spätkapitalismus, der strukturellen Gewalt im Spätkapitalismus und eines
Naturrechts auf Widerstand, das war das Wichtigste,
als der in Berlin war, war natürlich auch Rudi Dutsch gesaß auf dem Podium.
Also er war einfach immer derjenige, der dann die Reden hielt,
die die größte Faszination erregt haben.
Der hatte so eine heisere Stimme, er machte diese endlosen Sätze,
wo man eigentlich dachte, jetzt fliegt er irgendwann aus der Kurve.
Nein, er schafft dann noch irgendwie das richtige Verb da hinten ans Ende zu setzen.
Und er hatte diesen heiligen Ernst.
Also jemand, der brannte und lebte wirklich für die Revolution,
war aber auch ein ganz unschuldiger Mensch dabei.
Also in den Beirat hat er es 65 geschafft, das war dann wahrscheinlich seine
einzige offizielle Rolle.
Ja, das mag sein.
Was war denn dann so der Tipping Point in der Öffentlichkeit,
dass man sozusagen jetzt wirklich auf einmal von den 68ern sprach,
also wahrscheinlich sprach man, es ging ja auch 67 eigentlich alles los.
Also das mit den 68 und dann wurde er nicht von den 68 mehr geredet,
sondern von den alt 68, das fand ich immer putzig.
Die wurden zwar immer älter, aber waren schon immer die alt 68 und irgendwann waren sie wirklich alt.
Und also das ging alles erst eigentlich im Grunde in den 80er Jahren, 90er Jahren los,
als dann Konservative die 68er als das Grundübel der ganzen deutschen Geschichte
so ungefähr angesehen haben.
Aber wie hießen die damals?
Ja, die Studenten, die Radikalen, die Linksradikalen, die Jugendbewegung.
Denn das ist eigentlich das Interessante.
Man hat schon gesehen, als zum Beispiel es zu diesen schweren Unruhen kam in
über 20 Städten nach dem Attentat auf Rudi Dutschke,
war die Mehrzahl derjenigen, die festgenommen wurden, waren schon keine Studenten
mehr, sondern da waren junge Arbeiter, Schüler,
irgendwelche Leute dabei und.
Und aus dieser Studentenbewegung, die hoch intellektuell war,
man muss sich mal vorstellen, da sitzen 3.000, 4.000 Leute, drängen sich in
das Auditorium Maximum der FU, wo offiziell weniger als 2.000 Leute reinpassen,
rauchen auch noch zum Großteil.
Man sieht kaum mehr, was am anderen Ende des Saals passiert.
Sitzen da viele Stunden und hören hochkomplexen Diskussionen zu von Herbert
Marcuse mit Rudi Dutschke,
über die Befreiung des Menschen im Spätkapitalismus und was auch immer.
Also das ist auf einem theoretischen und intellektuellen Niveau,
was es heute im Grunde gar nicht mehr gibt.
Weiß nicht, ob es wirklich schade ist, dass es das nicht mehr gibt.
Aber ich könnte mir heute nicht vorstellen, dass so viele Leute,
tausend Leute da sitzen und mit Faszination dem folgen und auch so viele theoretische Bücher lesen.
Also Dutschke war auch so jemand, der… Ja, wenn es hochkommt.
Also das war auch eine Wiederaneignung von Literatur oder Denkern,
die im Faschismus eben auch in Vergessenheit geraten waren.
Also die linken Theoretiker, Jörg Lukacs und wen es so alles gab,
das wurde dann wiederentdeckt von den Ständen.
Oder Wilhelm Reich, die radikale Variante der Psychoanalyse.
Oder auch Freud wurde. wurde gelesen.
Der Krieg hat ja sicherlich auch so eine philosophische Lücke hinterlassen,
man hat sich halt einfach lange Zeit auch nicht mit sich beschäftigt.
Ja, die Weltanschauung war die des Nationalsozialismus und die war dann doch relativ schlicht.
Und also 68 war auch eine große sozusagen geistige Anstrengung oder eine geistige Bewegung, aber,
erfasste die gesamte Gesellschaft in den 70er Jahren und da brach sie dann eben
auch aus diesem kleinen, wir sind eine kleine radikale Minderheit,
brachen dann die Gedanken von 68 aus.
Also Dutschke ist 65 dazugekommen,
67 Finger sozusagen, begann es eigentlich erst alles richtig mit diesen Reden,
mit dieser Auseinandersetzung, es intensivierte sich und ich muss das jetzt
mal so vom Zeitstrahl her auch noch zusammenbekommen,
die die, wann war nochmal, Benni, ohne Sorg, die Demo war.
Am 2. Juni 1967.
Genau, so. Das heißt, da fing, damit fing es eigentlich.
Da brach plötzlich diese Studentenwilligen, die eigentlich mehr so in der Uni,
sich da im Campus, im schönen grünen Dahlem da bislang getummelt hatten und eine Hochschulreform,
gefordert hatten, da ging es in die ganze Stadt, da wurde es ein großer Konflikt
in West-Berlin und 1968 April,
Nach dem Attentat auf Rudi Dutschke sprang der Funken über von West-Berlin,
dieser absurden Insel, auf die ganze Bundesrepublik.
Und 1968 hat man plötzlich in Bremen irgendwelche Schüler an,
gigantische Aktionen gegen Fahrpreiserhöhungen zu machen. Oder in Hannover, Rote-Punkt-Aktion.
Plötzlich irgendwie überall waren irgendwelche meist langhaarigen Typen,
man muss auch sagen, in diesen politischen Gruppen damals waren eben 70 Prozent
Männer. und nur 30 Prozent Frauen.
Bei den Studenten waren 1968 drei Viertel Männer und nur ein Viertel Frauen.
Also das gehört auch zu dieser 68-Realität. Man sollte es nicht so verklären,
als ob da irgendwie plötzlich die Frauen alle gleichberechtigt gewesen wären.
Überhaupt nicht, stimmt gar nicht. Aber das ging dann 68 in die Provinz.
Irgendwann besetzten dann irgendwie, spielten Tonsteine Scherben irgendwo ein
Konzert im Hunsrück in irgendeiner Kleinstadt und danach marschierten alle und
besetzten ein Jugendzentrum, nannten das Autonomes Jugendzentrum.
Also so ging es dann 1968 los, aber der SDS als Organisation hat sich eben dann
schon wieder aufgelöst und die Führer dieser Studentenbewegung wollten dann
jeder so eine kleine Partei haben,
ist ja heute auch noch so, jeder will ein Außenminister sein und eine eigene
Briefmarke haben und dann gab es eben so Also Maoistische Parteien mehrere oder
es gab Trotzkisten oder die teilweise traten.
Viele der 68er sind in die SPD eingetreten, die haben eigentlich die meisten sozusagen abgekriegt.
Andere fanden die DDR dann super und die Mauer und den Zwangsumtausch,
den Inbegriff der Freiheit.
Aber auf jeden Fall 1969 zerfiel dann der SDS in ganz viele kleine Gruppen,
die auch dementsprechend wenig Einfluss hatten.
Und dann begann eigentlich so diese teilweise unmerkliche kulturelle Entwicklung.
Aus die kulturellen Auswirkungen von 68 und ja.
Ich wollte nochmal so ein bisschen diese Dynamik dieser kurzen Zeit irgendwie erfassen.
Also erst hat man so die Studenten, die sich intellektuell erstmal quasi mit
einem Neuanfang beschäftigen, aber doch noch sehr unter sich sind in gewisser Hinsicht.
Dann findet das sozusagen so ein bisschen sein Ventil in der Auseinandersetzung
mit diesem internationalen Konflikten, Vietnamkrieg auf der anderen Seite und
das andere dieses iranische, damalige iranische Regime,
der Schar also was ja glaube ich im Wesentlichen nur so ein Familienname ist,
der da halt auch über diese Generation wie so Könige weitergereicht wurde, also Mohammed Reza.
Pachtig Licht der Aria war einer seiner vielen Titel Licht der Aria Ja, aber sicher doch.
Das heißt, Deutschland hatte auch so ein besonderes Ding laufen irgendwie mit ihm oder was?
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, der kam dann und war dann sozusagen so eine Projektionsfläche auch dafür.
Sodass es zu dieser Demo kam und in dieser Schuss auf Beno Ohnesorg wurde ja
von diesem Berliner Polizisten Kuras ausgelöst, der sich ja dann,
wie sich jetzt erst vor wenigen Jahren herausstellte, der ja auch im Dienst der Stasi war.
Also sowas Irres konnte nur in West-Berlin damals passieren.
Also war das jetzt eine Aktion der Stasi oder war das Zufall?
Nein, der Stasi war das sehr peinlich. Die haben ihn sofort als Agenten abgeschaltet
und die hätten ihn auch, weil er sehr in der Stasi,
in der West-Berliner Polizei, die eine Spionageabwehr in Top-Posten hatten,
hätten die den nie für so einen Quatsch wie ein Studenten erschießen losgeschickt.
Er war viel zu guter und gut positionierter Agent. Die waren entsetzt.
Die haben ihn auch gesehen als so ein Waffennarr, der hat Geld von der Stasi
erreicht, 500, 600 Mark im Monat, was damals viel Geld war.
Das hat er alles in Munition umgesetzt und auf dem Schießplatz verballert,
der gute Koras, der dann noch 26 Jahre, glaube ich, Rente gekriegt hat.
Der ist friedlich, weil der ist zweimal freigesprochen worden,
alles ist und das hat die Studenten natürlich auch erbittert.
Die haben plötzlich die Justiz auch als Feind gesehen. Fritz Teufel,
Kommune 1, wurde eingesperrt am 2.
Juni 67, weil er angeblich Steine geworfen
haben soll und saß monatelang untersuchungshaft, stellt sich raus,
Polizei, Zeugen, Lügen, alles Quatsch, wird irgendwann dann auch freigelassen,
freigesprochen, aber der Typ, Der Polizist, der in Hinterkörper,
sitzt keinen Tag im Gefängnis, hatte noch seine private Schusswaffe im Gerichtssaal
in Moabit in der Tasche, wie hinterher rauskam.
Oh Gott.
Also ich meine, das waren schon Verhältnisse, muss man sagen,
die waren ziemlich irrwitzig, dass da Leute sich empört haben und auch ein Hass
gegen diese Klassenjustiz wurde das dann genannt.
Aber man kann es auch irgendwie einfach sozusagen eine Einäuge Justiz nennen.
Hatten ist doch klar. Also es war so, wenn man das Gefühl, hatten ganz viele
damals, wenn man aufsteht, was kritisiert, kritisiert und auch demonstriert
oder verhindern will, dass irgendwas passiert,
dann letzten Endes guckt man irgendwo einen Pistolenlauf.
So hart wird die Auseinandersetzung ausgetragen.
Und das war dann schon, es gab so diese Leichtigkeit, Hippies und Drogen und
sich gut fühlen und Gemeinschaftsgefühl.
Freie Liebe.
Ja, alles. Und psychedelisch und Farben und alles.
Happy auch. In den 60er Jahren waren auch so eine Zeit des Aufbruchs und wo
plötzlich Dinge möglich waren, die man nicht für möglich hielt.
Aber dann kam die knallharte Konfrontation mit der Staatsgewalt und dann zerfiel
auch die Bewegung wieder.
Ich glaube, es ist ganz banal, wenn man sich andere soziale Bewegungen anguckt,
sagen wir Hausbesitzer 1981, West-Berlin.
Irgendwann sozusagen.
Dann verschwindet das rebellische Subjekt. Die Leute werden in den Knast gesteckt
oder so. Andere sagen manchmal, ich muss doch mal meine Prüfung machen.
Im Dritten geht das Geld aus, ich muss nochmal wieder arbeiten gehen.
Also man kann sozusagen nicht paar tausend Leute können nicht als Berufsrevolutionäre
zehn Jahre lang rumrennen und versuchen irgendwas zu verändern,
sondern das geht immer so ein, zwei Jahre.
Dann ist die Dynamik auch so, dass so eine Bewegung auch dann irgendwie sich
ein bisschen erschöpft, sich ein bisschen zerstreitet.
Dann kommt die Gegenreaktion, die oft dann auch Leute abschreckt.
68 sind ja auch hunderte von Studentinnen und Studenten oder Demonstranten angeklagt
worden wegen Landfriedensbruch.
Wobei damals die Regierung so schlau war, Willy Brandt damals,
dass sie eine Amnestie bei so minderen Demonstrationsdelikten erlassen haben
und sich so erspart haben, dass die weiter sich radikalisiert hätten und dann
selber bewaffneten Kampf gemacht haben.
Aber die Repression schlägt dann zu, Und dann sagt man irgendwie,
man muss auch mal was anderes machen.
Man will auch nicht, jetzt sagen wir, immer mit jedem Abend sich treffen und
mit Leuten diskutieren und rumstreiten, sondern man will was,
vielleicht mal in Urlaub fahren oder was Unpolitisches machen.
Okay, um es nochmal kurz nochmal einzukreisen alles interessant Das Einkreisen ist dein Job.
Ich erzähle so Ja genau.
Das mache ich jetzt gerade mal Also nochmal so Also 67 ohne Sorg quasi der erste
Urknall, diese Radikalisierung die beginnt auf beiden Seiten die dann auch dazu
führt, dass Rudi Dutschke,
auf ihn dann das Attentat gemacht wird, das ist dann 68 im April glaube ich,
wo er zwar nicht getötet wird, aber so schwer verletzt wird,
dass er später auch in den Spätfolgen daran stirbt.
Er war auf jeden Fall auch aus dem Verkehr gezogen sozusagen,
um es mal salopp zu formulieren.
Und das heißt, und das wird ja dann auch nochmal für Aufregung gesorgt haben,
das heißt, das Jahr 68 vermute ich mal war eine wilde Auseinandersetzung mit
dieser Gruppe, die sich wahrscheinlich in dem Moment sowohl verstärkt hat,
als auch begonnen hat, sich neu zu zerstreiten.
Wann ist sozusagen, wann läuft das aus? Wenn man 69 kommt, dann Willy Brandt
als Bundeskanzler ins Amt, war das dann schon eine Reaktion?
War das sozusagen eine Folge davon? Oder war das eher Zufall?
Hat er es denn tatsächlich geschafft, das sozusagen zu containen?
Oder war das eher auch nur so ein Beiprodukt?
Also es wäre vielleicht übertrieben zu sagen, dass die 68er den Regierungswechsel
von der CDU zur SPD bewerkstelligt hätten.
Aber es war schon diese Welle, auf der Willy Brandt dann auch geschwommen ist.
Ob er so reiten wollte, weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber dass zum ersten Mal ein,
Erklärter Antifaschist, der Deutschland verlassen hatte in Zeiten des Nationalsozialismus,
Bundeskanzler werden konnte, der Vaterlandsverräter, wie so die Trechten immer
gesagt haben, Fram, das war sein Deckname als Kommunist in Norwegen,
dass der Bundeskanzler werden konnte und dass dann eine sozialliberale,
und damals war die FDP eben wirklich eine liberale Partei, an die Regierung
kam und bestimmte Reformen auch dann einsetzten.
Das war natürlich ein Ergebnis auch von 68.
Allerdings, und das ist das Absurde und auch eigentlich bizarre und triste.
Die Aktivisten oder ein beachtlicher Teil der Aktivisten von 68 sahen in der
Regierung Brandt einen Polizeistaat,
der sich zum Faschismus hin entwickelt.
In Wahrheit war es ja eine neue Ostpolitik, es war eine Modernisierung,
die in Gang kam, eine Liberalisierung, Amerikanisierung, auch Deutschland wurde
nochmal entnazifiziert auf eine Art durch die 68er und bloß die wollten ja irgendwie
die Weltrevolution und sahen nicht, dass das durchaus Fortschritte sind.
Die sich dann durch die Regierung brannt und wieder langsam durchgesetzt haben.
Und ja wiederum
auf der anderen Seite Willy Brandt war der Kanzler der dann sogenannte Berufsverbote
erlassen hat das haben ja damals tausende sei es irgendwie der berühmte Brieftäger
der DKB der dann nicht mehr Brieftäger weil die damals Beamten waren,
viele durften nicht Lehrer werden,
eine ganze Reihe dieser auch führenden Berliner 68er, Peter Schneider,
Bernd Rabel haben Berufsverbot damals bekommen.
Das heißt, die SPD hat wie immer so die SPD halt mit ja, auch mit der Peitsche
versucht oder mit Repression versucht, die Linken im Schach zu halten.
Aber sie sind natürlich auch von dieser Aufwahlung 68 unterstützt worden,
an die Macht gebracht worden.
Und das heißt, Deutschland hat eigentlich ausgelöst durch die 68er ein wenig
getragen durch diesen Zeitgeist sich dann mehr oder weniger Willy Brandt,
wenn auch nur für kurze Zeit, rangeholt.
Er ist zurückgetreten durch diese Spionage, ausgelöst durch diese Spionageaffäre.
Ja, aber ich meine, es gab bis 1981, danach folgte Helmut Schmidt,
gab es eine von der SPD geführte Bundesregierung, ist ja auch nicht das Übliche in diesem Land.
Ja, aber in der Zeit ging ja dieser ganze Konflikt auch weiter,
also weil, da sollten wir jetzt vielleicht mal kommen, also ich denke die 68er
werden eigentlich in den 70ern, das ist richtig interessant,
weil das ja dann sozusagen, das eine ist so dieses Aufbäumen,
das ist so ein Feuer, was auf einmal brennt, da wird dann von allen Seiten so
lange drauf gehauen, bis erstmal Ruhe ist, aber sowas, und das haben wir ja
eben schon auch gehört, diese Radikalisierung einzelner,
beziehungsweise ein Mentalitätswandel, der sich dann vielleicht nicht unmittelbar,
aber mittelbar bei vielen auch einstellt, das trägt ja dann erst später seine Früchte.
Wann hast du denn das Gefühl gehabt, dass sozusagen dieses Echo dieser Zeit wieder aufkam?
Also du sagst ganz richtig, das wahre 68 spielte sich in den 70ern ab.
Aber von Echo kann man nicht sprechen, denn es gab ja einen beständigen,
Also jetzt mal, wenn ich von mir spreche, ich war 68, 13.
Da bin ich auch so mehr zufällig, habe ich dann Engels, Lohn,
Preis, Profit, so Marx, Schulung und so mit 15 da gesessen, irgendwie so Heftchen da gelesen.
Mich gewundert, fand es aber ziemlich interessant eigentlich kommunistisches Manifest gelesen und,
aber also mit 13 versteht man noch nicht viel von der Welt, mit 15 auch nicht,
aber dann entwickelten sich eben Anfang der 70er Jahre, gab es dann Schülerbewegungen,
also es wurden immer mehr,
das war das Entscheidende, es wuchsen sozusagen die von den Jungen im Sog der
wenigen 68er, SDS an der Spitze als intellektuelle, auch ein bisschen elitäre Organisation,
kamen ja dann Tausende, Zehntausende, Hunderttausende von irgendwelchen jungen
Leuten, die langen Haare hatten. Dann fingen alle an zu kiffen.
Dann zog man in Wohngemeinschaften. Das war nicht nur die Kommune 1,
die dann im Stern irgendwie da posierte, sondern das war ja eine Massenbewegung
von Wohngemeinschaften.
Da muss man sich klar machen, so eine WG war damals undenkbar.
Also war vorher undenkbar.
Ja, das war Da dachten dann alle an Gruppensex oder irgendwelchen Unsinn,
der da nie stattgefunden hatte.
Was?
Alles Mythos, muss man wirklich sagen. Diese sexuelle Revolution,
die hat mit 68 nicht so viel zu tun.
Es gibt ein berühmtes Foto, was da immer gezeigt wird, die Kommune 1 nackt von hinten.
Sieben Erwachsene und ein Kind, was sich so umdreht und sich fragt, was ist denn hier los?
An die Wand, stellen sich so an die Wand. Und bei diesem Foto sagen mehrere,
die da auch darauf abgebildet waren und sich da als Models haben zur Verfügung
gestellt, sagen, wir waren froh,
als wir endlich unsere Klamotten wieder anhalten. Das war uns so peinlich.
Also es war nicht so. Natürlich gab es irgendwie dann so in den ersten Kommunen
immer so Matratzenlager, ein Zimmer voll mit Matratzen, wo dann irgendwie alle pennten.
Aber es war doch irgendwie peinlich,
wenn dann irgendwie daneben einer vögelt oder ein paar da vögelt.
So richtig wohl fühlte man sich dabei auch nicht. Also das ist immer übertrieben worden,
aber ein Beispiel sollten wir mal nehmen, wie 68 dann in den 70ern eigentlich
zum Durchbruch kam, das sind die Frauen, die Feministinnen.
Es gab eine SDS-Delegiertenkonferenz im September 1968 in Frankfurt und da tauchte
auf eine damals 30 Jahre alte Filmstudentin von der DFB aus Berlin namens Helke Sander.
Die vertrat den Aktionsrat zur Vorbereitung der Befreiung der Frau Vorbereitung
haben sie dann bald gestrichen an dieser Aktionsrat zur Befreiung der Frau,
und stellte sich hin und sagte also wenn der SDS überhaupt von sich behaupten
will irgendwie fortschrittlich und demokratisch zu sein,
dann muss er sich mit der Frage der Frauen beschäftigen und das heißt,
dann muss die Erziehung von Kindern Helge Sander.
Die Rednerin hatte ein Kind damals, dann müssen die Männer endlich da auch mal was tun.
Dann muss das irgendwie verteilt werden, damit die Frauen sich auch politisch
betätigen können, damit die Frauen arbeiten gehen können, damit die Frauen überhaupt
gleichberechtigt mit den Männern agieren können.
Und diese Rede haben die Männer auf dieser SDS-Delegiertenkonferenz einfach
gar nichts gesagt. Da kam gar nichts.
Und als dann der Sitzungsleiter zum nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt übergehen wollte,
nahm eine Berliner Studentin eine Tomate, aber sie hatte mehrere,
und warf die in Richtung Rednerpult.
Und eine Tomate traf dann auch einen, der da vorne saß.
Nämlich den Kral, der war so ein Frankfurter, der intellektuelle Führer der
Frankfurter Studenten, traf natürlich den Falschen, denn der war schwul und
hatte also mit Frauenunterdrückung praktisch wenig zu tun.
Und gut, aber in dieser Rede sagt im Grunde Helge Sander, wir wollen Gleichberechtigung,
die Männer sollen sich um das Persönliche kümmern,
das Persönliche ist politisch, es geht nicht darum, immer nur so große Weltrevolution
und dann die ganzen Sachen, die zwischen uns schief laufen, werden dann danach
irgendwann vielleicht gelöst oder auch nicht, sondern wir müssen heute damit
anfangen, auch in unserem Alltag Dinge zu verändern.
Auch sie sagt damals schon 1968, dass es darum geht in der Welt des Falschen,
Inseln des Richtigen, also utopische Projekte anzufangen,
Kollektive und solche Dinge, um dann ja eine Massenwirksamkeit darüber zu sein.
Das ist alles schon 1968 irgendwie da angelegt und das geht dann noch so ein
bisschen im SDS weiter und dann,
Steht dann in Berlin, das ist aber schon 1973, tun sich Frauen zusammen und
sagen, wir gründen jetzt mal ein autonomes Frauenzentrum.
Das gab es dann auch in Kreuzberg in der Hornstraße, da durften keine Männer
rein, standen aber immer Fächer vor der Türe und waren beleidigt,
dass sie nicht rein durften.
Und da haben dann Frauen angefangen, also einmal Karate zu machen,
Selbsthilfe, Verteidigung gegen die Männer.
Männergewalt, Frauengesundheitszentrum, haben damals Abtreibung,
waren ja nahezu illegal in Deutschland, haben Abtreibungsfahrten in die Niederlande
organisiert, haben sich mit Frauen aus anderen europäischen Ländern getroffen.
Also in den 70er Jahren sind diese Ideen, Gleichheit Männer und Frauen ist an
sich so banal, banaler geht es kaum.
1968 im STS öffentlich debattiert und in den 70er Jahren geht es in die Gesellschaft und es werden mehr.
Und es kommt der Stern und Alice Schwarzer und die machen diese Aktion,
auch ich habe abgetrieben.
Und dann kommt wieder die sozialliberale Regierung, Willy Brandt,
die reformieren den Paragrafen 218. Es verändert sich gesellschaftlich was.
Und so gibt es eben, Pradik Matsch ist wohl das Frauenthema,
Aber so gibt es bestimmte Ideen, die in den 60er Jahren hochkamen,
in einer kleinen, wie es immer ist, kleine Subkultur, SDS und Zirkelchen.
Da wird irgendwas gedacht und dann diffundiert das so langsam in die Gesellschaft
und wird in die Gesellschaft getragen und führt dann irgendwann zu realen Veränderungen.
Und es ist ja eine Banalität und oft gesagt worden, aber ohne die 68er und Frauen
wie Helge Sander und Alice Schwarzer hätten wir auch nicht Angela Merkel so
lange als Bundeskanzlerin eine Frau ist, ging ja gar nicht.
Ja.
Ja, ich denke, das ist eben etwas, das ist auch, glaube ich,
so einer der Gründe, warum ich hier dieses Thema auch so einbringen wollte,
sodass viel von dem, was so in unserer heutigen Wahrnehmung der Bundesrepublik so
selbstverständlich erscheint.
Eben vor noch gar nicht so langer Zeit, also je nachdem, ob man jetzt 50 Jahre
als lange bezeichnen möchte oder nicht.
Aber es gab auf jeden Fall definitiv auch ein Westdeutschland zumindest,
wo das auch mal ganz anders war.
Ostdeutsche Situation haben wir jetzt bisher ein bisschen rausgelassen.
Vielleicht eine gute Gelegenheit mal zu schauen, wie denn das und ob überhaupt
das so im Osten auch reflektiert wurde.
Also,
Der große Unterschied war natürlich der, dass in der DDR sobald, sagen wir,
jemand demonstriert hat auf der Straße, ohne dass das irgendwie von staatlichen
Institutionen abgesegnet worden wäre, war die Stasi da und dann war die VP da,
die Volkspolizei und hat die Leute abgeräumt.
Es gab ja eine groteske Überwachung auch von Oppositionellen.
Die saßen aber eigentlich im Wesentlichen, es reichte schon in deinem Wohnzimmer
zu sitzen mit fünf Freunden und über Alternativen zur DDR nachzudenken.
Schon warst du ja negativ feindlich und gefährlich und bist überwacht worden.
Es gab aber trotzdem 1968 zwei Aktionen in Ostberlin im Wesentlichen,
die gezeigt haben, dass da irgendwas zwischen jungen Oppositionellen in Ost
und West so mitschwingt oder dass die was gemeinsam haben.
Und zwar hat einmal 1968, nach dem Attentat auf Rudi Dutschke,
hat in Ostberlin ein späterer Schriftsteller, damaliger Journalist, Klaus Schlesinger.
Lange Haare, immer so ein Club, Jazzmusik gehört, mit einem Freund Stefan Schnitzler
und anderen, die haben überlegt, was können wir, irgendwie gefallen die uns da drüben.
Waren das gleiche Alter dann hat
der Schlesinger zum Beispiel Dutschke gesehen berühmtes Interview
mit Günther Gaußen und hatte sich gewundert die benutzen
so marxistische Begriffe die für uns total ausgelatscht und irgendwie schwer
erträglich sind aber die benutzen die in einer neuen Art und Weise und irgendwie
das hört sich zwar ähnlich an zu dem was wir hier andauernd bis zum Abbrechen
zu hören bekommen aber irgendwie meinen die wohl was anderes und,
Die beiden haben dann zusammen mit Freunden Geld gesammelt,
zum Beispiel im Deutschen Theater kamen 2500 Mark der DDR damals zusammen unter
den Schauspielern und haben Geld gesammelt für Bauhelme,
die sie gekauft haben und dann gespendet haben der APO, also der Außerparlamentarischen Opposition,
den Studenten im Westen.
Und es wurde so von der Stasi so etwas misstrauisch irgendwie so beäugt und
aber da da auch so eine Igge Keller, Nationalpreisträgerin dabei war.
Haben die das dann laufen lassen und dann kamen Leute, auch zwei von zwei,
die später bei der RAF waren,
kamen dann 68 und haben in so einem Milchladen,
also so Vienstraße dann jeweils vier so Bauarbeiterhelme
gekriegt und Regenmäntel gegen die Wasserwerfer und das
war so eine Aktion praktischer Solidarität und es gründete dann auch so Freundschaften
also dann kamen linke Studenten aus dem Westen sind dann nach Ostberlin gefahren
haben da Leute wieder getroffen und Wobei.
Diese Begegnungen ja eigentlich auch erst durch die Maßnahmen von Willy Brandt
möglich geworden sind also vorher war doch so ein unmittelbares Einreisen von Westberlinern in.
Den Osten Doch, nee, nee, nee. Es gab zwei Jahre nach dem Bau der Mauer,
da konnten Westberliner nicht nach Ostberlin fahren, aber das wurde natürlich
Passierscheinabkommen 63 schon wieder alles geregelt.
Aber das Interessante daran war, dass das Thema, was Ostlinke oder Ostrebellen
und Westrebellen verbunden hat,
war der Versuch in der Tschechoslowakei im Prager Frühling, im sogenannten einen
freiheitlichen Sozialismus zu schaffen.
Denn was, und das geht durch, was Rebellen in Ost- und West-Berlin immer verbunden
hat, war eigentlich der Versuch.
Das Bedürfnis, mit autoritären Strukturen aufzuräumen.
Freiheit, freie Diskussionen zu haben und von daher guckten,
also sowohl die West-Berlin-Linke, Rudi Dutschke ist 1968 nochmal nach Prag gereist auch,
bevor er angeschossen wurde und hat sich das angeschaut und war begeistert.
Also der Versuch dort, die Zensur zum Beispiel aufzuheben, Pressefreiheit einzuführen,
das wurde von jungen Leuten der DDR mit großem Wohlwollen und Sympathie verfolgt
und von jungen Westberliner Studenten.
Und als dann die Truppen des Warschauer Paktes und der Führung der Sowjet-Truppen
einmarschierten und die Panzer diese Demokratiebewegung im Sozialismus niederwalzten,
obwohl die ja nicht, die wollten ja nicht den Kapitalismus einführen,
sondern wollten einfach einen freiheitlichen Sozialismus haben,
als das niedergewalzt wurde,
da fingen dann an junge Ostberliner Flugblätter zu machen.
Thomas Brasch zum Beispiel, der Schriftsteller später, der inzwischen gestorben
ist, verteilte Flugblätter.
Seine damalige Freundin Bettina Wegner, später bekannte Sängerin,
verteilte Flugblätter.
Und die wurden natürlich erwischt und Stasi und ins Gefängnis gesperrt.
Und dann irgendwie bekam sie ein Berufsverbot.
Bettina Wegner musste dann irgendwo sich in der Produktion bewähren, in irgendeinem Werk.
Und das heißt, da war die Reaktion natürlich viel härter.
Aber nicht nur in Ostberlin. Es gab auch in allen möglichen anderen Städten in der DDR damals,
Einzelne und Gruppen, die ihren Protest ausgedrückt haben und das hängt wieder
glaube ich zusammen mit diesem globalen, denn die Musik,
die die in der DDR gehört haben, die jungen Leute mit langen Haaren,
die haben ja auch Blues gehört oder davor Jazz und in Westberlin war ja im Grunde ähnlich.
Also es gab auch in der DDR, die ja im Alltag und so vom Protokoll her spießiger
so war als der Westen, gab es natürlich auch junge Leute, die gesagt haben,
also weg mit diesem ganzen Mummenschanz, wir wollen freier leben, wir sind Individuen.
Sozialismus mit menschlichen Antlitz hieß es damals.
Ja, oder der dritte Weg hieß es, da gab es allerhand Namen dafür.
Aber wie dem auch sei, also die Vorstellung, dass es nur die Alternative gibt,
entweder Kapitalismus und dann irgendwie so eine repräsentative,
aber nicht besonders demokratische Demokratie oder aber eine Diktatur, eine stalinistische,
die dann die Gleichheit schafft.
Also das wollten eben die jungen Leute nicht, sondern es musste irgendwas anderes geben.
Einen freiheitlichen Sozialismus. War im Grunde in den Wendejahren dann später
bei der DDR-Opposition.
Die Leute, die Ostberliner, die 1990 Häuser besetzt haben oder die Ende der
80er Jahre gesagt haben, jetzt ist aber Schluss mit hier immer nur Kaffee trinken
zusammen und Lesungen machen und in der Wohnung sitzen.
Wir gehen jetzt auf die Straße, wir gehen nochmal demonstrieren, wir gehen Risiko ein.
Die haben eigentlich alle, sagen alle, nee, also den Scheißkapitalismus von
euch, den wollten wir eigentlich nicht. Oder den wollen wir eigentlich nicht.
Das war ja auch noch so ein kurzer Traum.
89. Aber sozusagen es gibt in beiden Teilen Berlins und in beiden Deutschlands
gab es damals Jugendliche,
die sich auch sofort gut verstanden haben oder vom Lebensgefühl gut miteinander,
klarkamen und die dann alle gemeinsam Tonscheine Scherben gehört haben,
die in Ostberlin fast noch populärer waren als in Westberlin.
Also es gab so anarchistische, linke, freiheitliche Gruppen von Leuten,
die sofort zueinander gefunden haben.
Kommen wir zurück zu den 70ern und den Auswirkungen der 68er ich weiß nicht
genau wo ich da jetzt mich wieder auf die Gleise setzen soll wie lange das so
ein bisschen vor sich hin sich entwickelt hat und wann so eine Dramatisierung,
wieder Einzug gehalten hat.
Also bei den 70ern finde ich muss mal erstmal sehen dass,
Die Gruppe, die in den 70ern die meiste Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat und aus
den 60ern kam, hieß Rote Armee Fraktion RAF,
ungefähr 30 Leute, Terroristen,
die dachten, sie müssten jetzt einen Bürgerkrieg vom Zaun brechen oder sie müssten
als Propaganda der Tat bewaffnet gegen den Staat vorgehen und dann würde das
irgendwann in der sozialen Revolution münden.
Diese Gruppe hat natürlich viel zu viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und all die Leute,
die jetzt sagen wir Jugendzentren gegründet haben oder ein Frauenzentrum gegründet
haben oder irgendwann dann später sich für ökologische Ziele eingesetzt haben,
die sind da unter den Tisch gefallen.
Es war immer Andreas Bader und die RAF.
Und das ist bedauerlich, aber die Medien sind halt so. Wo Blut fließt,
gucken sie hin. Wenn kein Blut fließt, Gottchen.
Ist nicht dramatisch. Ist dann auch nicht so wichtig.
Und die ganzen sieben Jahre, von 1970 bis 1977, Von der Befreiung Andreas Baders
in der Miegwellstraße in Dahlem am 14.
Mai 1970 bis zur Stammheimer Todesnacht, dem Tod von Andreas Bader wieder und
Gudrun Enzlund Jan Kalraspe in Stammheim im Gefängnis in Stammheim Stuttgart,
waren sehr stark dominiert von den Aktionen dieser Gruppe.
Die wurden dann mal verhaftet 72, gab es einen großen Prozess und die Linke hat,
ja gesehen, dass die kommen irgendwie von uns, die sind zwar irre oder machen
Fehler oder haben eine falsche Strategie, aber irgendwie als Opfer des Staates
müssen wir auch mit ihnen soldatisch sein das heißt,
die RAF hat in den Jahren 70 bis 77 stark die.
Radikale Linke beschäftigt dann gab es so,
ein Wandel, so ein Paradigmenwechsel, den die Beteiligten gar nicht so richtig
verstanden und unbedingt so gewollt hatten,
der hat sich ausgedrückt in dem Kongress Ende Januar, ich glaube 26.
Januar in Westberlin, der den Namen Tunix hatte und wo eigentlich klar war,
wir wollen mit dieser Vorstellung von Weltrevolution und dem marxistischen Vorstellung,
die Arbeiterklasse, wo ist denn die eigentlich, die Arbeiterklasse in West-Berlin,
die paar, die noch in einer Schokoladenfabrik an einer verlängerten Werkbank saßen,
also auf die konnte man nicht ernsthaft zählen.
Also mit diesen marxistischen Vorstellungen aufzuhören und jetzt,
Zu sagen, wir verschleißen uns nicht im Kampf gegen den Staat,
sondern wir versuchen in dieser Gesellschaft, die sich ja schon geöffnet hat,
wo es alles mögliche in Bewegung ist, wo es unzufriedene Menschen gibt,
wo es Leute gibt, die was machen wollen.
Wir versuchen darin, so Inseln des Richtigen im Falschen aufzuschütten.
Jetzt sind wir ja schon Ende der 70er Jahre angekommen. Das war so ein bisschen der Schnelldurchlauf.
Aber das Entscheidende ist eben, dass am Anfang das sehr stark noch dominiert
war von dieser Auseinandersetzung mit Gewalt und Terrorismus und da ist ja dann
selbst so ein friedlicher,
netter Mensch wie Heinrich Böll ist unter die Räder gekommen.
Bei dem hat das Bundeskriminalamt dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
mit geladenen Maschinenpistolen und seinem Wochenendhaus mal vorbeigeschaut.
Also ich meine, es war ja eine hysterische Situation, Berufsverbote und eben
dieses Terrorismus-Hysterie.
Sind nicht entschuldigend, aber man muss auch wissen, dass die Polizeiführungen
zum Beispiel und auch so die Politiker, die waren auf so einen Angriff aber
auch nicht da eingerichtet.
Also die Demonstrationen der Studenten, da haben die völlig überreagiert.
Heute sind die richtig verdammt nochmal richtig schlau, wie die deeskalieren,
so die Bullerei auf der gleichen Seite aber extrem hochgerüstet sind und auch brutal zuschlagen.
Hat jetzt gerade in Hamburg wieder nicht so gut funktioniert Ja,
Aber da haben ja die Berliner dann gesagt Also die Berliner haben ausgelernt
Ja, die Hamburger Naja, also sozusagen es war irgendwie auch.
Ende der 60er und dann Anfang der 70er Jahre prallten da so zwei Kräfte aufeinander.
Da gab es natürlich immer, wenn Gewalt im Spiel ist, ist die Gefahr der Eskalation
sehr groß und der Rache und dann geht es immer weiter.
Und das war eigentlich in den 70er Jahren sehr stark.
Und für diejenigen, die im Herzen der Studentenbewegung tätig waren,
für die war das sehr hart.
Also ich kenne eine sehr nette Frau, Antje Krüger, die war in der Kommune 1
zum Beispiel und da war eben Fritz Teufel und auch Rainer Langhans,
aber die hat eben ganz viele wie Fritz Teufel und die kannte auch Bader und
Enstlin, hat die verschwindend sehen in den bemerkenden Untergrund,
dann irgendwie bei der Fahndung erschossen oder im Gefängnis unter harten Haftbewegungen sitzend.
Und für die Leute war das, glaube ich, ungeheuer hart.
Die sagt immer, Antje Krüger sagt immer, auch die 60er waren irgendwie noch
so ein bisschen leicht und happy und die 70er Jahre waren furchtbar hart.
Das heißt, auch wenn es immer darum geht, die 68er haben alle Karriere gemacht,
alle Professoren kriegen Krisen, Pensionen. Stimmt nicht.
Also diejenigen, die wirklich was riskiert haben, nehmen wir mal an,
die Leute von der Kommune 1, die ja auch ziemlich zu einer Öffentlichkeit standen,
Und da kenne ich allein drei, die sind harter.
Die haben keine Beamten. Die in der zweiten Reihe oder dritten Reihe,
da haben viele Karriere gemacht.
Aber diejenigen, die wirklich was verändern wollten und dann in der ersten Reihe
standen, da hat es viele ziemlich erwischt.
Hart aufgelaufen.
Ja.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal auf die,
auf diese RAF nochmal spezifisch, weil die ja dann eigentlich in der Folge wiederum
so viel anderes ausgelöst hat.
Nicht als Vorbild, sondern eben als Widerstandsobjekt.
Diese Radikalisierung von Horst Mahler finde ich ja sowieso irgendwie die tragischste Figur.
Tragisch ist schon fast übertrieben.
So weit nach dem richtigen Wort. Eine Person, die ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen
kann, sagen wir es mal so.
Also die sowohl jetzt mit der Gründung der RAF verbunden wird,
als auch heutzutage wiederum im extrem rechtsradikalen, rechtsextremen Umfeld unterwegs ist.
Aber Horst Mahler, das sagen zumindest die Leute, die ihn gut kennen,
auch von früher, Otto Schiedig zum Beispiel und sein damaliger Anwaltskollege
oder Christian Schrebel, die sagen alle,
die sagen, das ist tragisch und das ist eigentlich nur individualpsychologisch zu erklären.
Man muss dazu wissen, zum Beispiel, dass Horst Mahlers Vater in Glündern Nationalsozialist
war und dann aber irgendwie in die DDR gerät und sich eines Sonntags nach dem
Mittagessen im Garten ging und sich in den Kopf geschossen hat.
Und Horst Mahler ist dann von der FDJ in der DDR zu den Linken in der SPD.
Dann SDS, RAF, dann FDP, dann war noch mal KPD, so mau ist, also der hat im
Grunde alle Stationen des politischen Hauptsache extrem.
Ja, Hauptsache, nein, das ist masochistisch. Hauptsache Opfer.
Der sitzt jetzt auch mit einem Bein amputiert wegen Holocaust-Leugnung.
Ich glaube schon seit 10 Jahren im Gefängnis.
Was ich persönlich auch ein Unding
finde für Meinungen, Leute so lange einzusperren, egal welche Meinung.
Solange der nicht zum Mord aufruft. Es gibt auch Leute, die daran glauben,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist.
Sollen wir die auch alle einsperren? Ich bin gegen Gesinnungsjustiz. jeder Art.
Gut, aber Hausmaler ist wirklich ein Freak, also ein,
Ja, Ausnahme. Die anderen haben eigentlich, naja, haben sich integriert in diese Gesellschaft.
Also wenn man sich anguckt, Joschka Fischer, Außenminister.
Ja gut, der war jetzt nicht bei der RAF dabei.
Nee, der war nicht bei der RAF dabei, aber der war auch so bei diesem Militantenflügel.
Und warum Einzelne dann diesen Schritt gemacht haben in die Illegalität und
das hat teilweise zufällig, das hat persönliche Gründe.
Und also es ging ja alles los, dass Andreas Bader wegen einer Kaufhausbrandstiftung
in Berlin im Gefängnis hat.
Und dann ist halt seine Freundin Gudrun Ensslin rumgelaufen in der Westberliner Szene.
Die machen den kaputt, Andreas, wir müssen ihn rausholen. Dann hat es ein paar
Frauen mobilisiert und haben sich irgendwelche Waffen gekauft.
Und dann ist bei dieser Befreiungsaktion gleich einer angeschossen worden und
lebensgefährlich verletzt worden. Und dann gab es diese Spirale,
große Fahndung nach Ulrike Meinhof, die überhaupt sich darauf nicht vorbereitet war.
Und dann wurden RAF-Leute bei der Fahndung erschossen, dann geht es um Rache,
die Schweine haben Petra Schelm umgebracht, jetzt schlagen wir zurück.
Und dann hat sich ein ja so ein selbsterklärter Krieg der RAF gegen den Staat entwickelt der.
Weder zu gewinnen war und der auch dazu führte,
dass die Mittel ja dann teilweise absucht waren dann wurde bei einem Richter
des Bundesgerichtshofs eine Bombe und das Auto gebaut unter seinen VW und dann
schick seine Frau ein und wurde lebensgefährlich verletzt, weil die einkaufen fahren wollte.
Also passierten dann wirklich irre Sachen und die Linken fanden das am Anfang daneben,
wurde ja dann bekannt, dass Andreas Bader gerne Porsche fährt zum Beispiel und
selten italienische Sportwagen klaut und mit denen dann durch die Gegend heizt.
Ja und als sie dann im Gefängnis saßen mussten, waren aber dann viele wieder
solidarisch und haben gesagt, also gegen diese Isolationshaft müssen wir dann doch solidarisch sein.
Im Grunde kann man Helmut Schmidt fast dankbar sein, dass er dem Spuk ein Ende
gesetzt hat 1977 und dann auf der militärischen Ebene, die aber die Raffa gesucht
hat, dann die RAF besiegt hat.
Danach gab es es zwar noch leider viel zu lange, aber.
Auf welche Art und Weise besiegt hat?
Indem er nicht nachgegeben hat und nicht, damals als Hans-Martin Schleyer im
September, Oktober 1977 entführt worden war bei der RAF, nicht nachgegeben hat
und die RAF-Leute in Stammheim rausgelassen hat.
Sondern sich gesagt hat, da müssen wir durch,
wenn wir hier nachgeben, dann machen sie die nächste Aktion und wollen noch
mehr befreien oder wollen uns weiter erpressen und da ganz vernünftig,
ruhig, machiavellistisch hat er das durchgezogen und die RAF hat sich da auch
taktisch dann verschätzt und damit war aber auch so gut wie dem allerletzten
klar, dass so geht es überhaupt nicht.
Man kann nicht, um jemanden zu entführen, wie es bei der Schleierentführung
passiert war, einfach drei Begleiter mal zersieben mit Schüssen und umbringen.
Also das war dann, diese Sackgasse war endgültig erkannt, aber es dauerte eben
sieben Jahre, wobei in diesen sieben Jahren natürlich auch dann ganz viele andere Sachen passierten.
Es kam dann, das ist eigentlich für die 70er Jahre für mich das Entscheidende,
der Bericht des Club of Rome raus.
Ich glaube es war 1973 wurde der veröffentlicht, die Grenzen des Wachstums,
die einfach so banale Ideen, dass irgendwann die fossilen Brennstoffe verbraucht
sein werden und man sich vielleicht was anderes überlegen könnte,
dann populär gemacht haben und da entstand die,
Jetzt erstmal gar nicht so in einem linksradikalen Milieu, aber es entstanden
dann so Bürgerinitiativen und Gruppen, die sich über Ökologie Gedanken machten.
Das hatte durchaus was mit den 60ern zu tun, denn ich habe mal ein paar Monate
in den 60ern in einer Landkommune im Bayerischen Wald verbracht.
Und unsere Vorstellung damals, also so biodynamische Landwirtschaft,
ich weiß nicht, ob wir es so genannt haben, aber keine chemische Landwirtschaft,
Tiere besser behandeln,
Energiesparen, irgendwie, ich glaube, wir haben schon so Sonnenkollektoren,
irgendwie auch da so die ersten gebaut, das war eigentlich so in den 60er Jahren
war das schon so ein bisschen angelegt und das wurde ja dann neben der,
Frauenbewegung wurde das die entscheidende Strömung der 70er Jahre,
die das Denken in Deutschland und die deutsche Gesellschaft wirklich verändert hat.
Biologisch-dynamisch kommt ja aus dieser Rudolf Steiner anthroposophischen Ecke
der Begriff, so Demeter und so weiter, das kennt man ja heute auch noch so als Markenphänomen,
auf dem Markt, aber stimmt schon, diese ganze Ökologisierung hat sich da extrem,
verstärkt, sag ich mal.
Dieses Bewusstsein auf das Erhalten der Welt etc.
Also wahrscheinlich kann dieser
Club of Rome Bericht tatsächlich so eine Initialzündung gewesen sein.
Der kam noch vor der sogenannten Anti-AKW-Bewegung. Entzündeten sich ja dann
eigentlich so die auch furchtbar militante Auseinandersetzungen,
wenn ich daran denke, wie in Brockdorf die Baustelle des Atomreaktors belagert
wurde oder auch in Wiel dann der Bauplatz für ein AKW besetzt wurde.
Die Anti-AKW-Bewegung so ab 75 ging es dann in Wiel los und wurde dann 78,
79 zu der beherrschenden innenpolitischen Auseinandersetzung auch,
die eigentlich zum Glück mit einem Sieg der,
damaligen Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten geendet hat.
Frau Merkel hat ja irgendwann den Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie verkündet,
was wir schon damals gefordert haben.
Das waren viele Demonstrationen nötig, aber so einfach, als sieht man politische
Erfolge auch nicht immer.
Ja gut, verkündet wurde ja schon früher, als wir in Rotfühlen...
Von Rotfühlen kam es wieder in kurzem Schlenker.
Genau, und noch ist es auch nicht vorbei. Ich denke, es ist jetzt schon vorbei, aber andere Frage.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Parallelentwicklung.
Auf der einen Seite erstmal diese Befreiung des Einzelnen in der Gesellschaft,
gegen diese vorherrschenden Mantras.
Am Anfang stand, sich das irgendwie auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise auch politisiert,
internationalisiert hat.
Dann so eine extreme Radikalisierung auf der einen Seite durch die RAF und dann
aber eben auch neue Themen aufgenommen wurden, die so vorher noch gar nicht auf der Agenda waren.
Eine Friedensbewegung, das leitet sich natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht schon
aus dem Vietnamkrieg ab.
Ja, der Pazifismus der 60er Jahre, Peace-Zeichen.
Ja, genau. Aber die ökologische Bewegung als solche war, ich will ja auch nicht
sagen neu, weil so Naturschützer und so weiter gab es in Bayern auch schon wie 50 Jahre davor,
aber es wurde eine breite Bewegung, es wurde auch Teil dieser Mentalitäten in den 70er Jahren.
Ölkrise, setzt da ein etc. Es ging in den Mainstream. Das wollte ich sagen.
Und das sind eben die beiden Themen, es gibt noch andere Themen,
aber die beiden wichtigsten Themen,
die in den 60ern sozusagen geboren wurden und dann in den 70ern zu massiven
Veränderungen geführt haben, sind einmal die Frauen, Gleichberechtigung.
Kann man auch noch mitnennen, dass die Schwulen nicht ständig diskriminiert werden.
Es gab ja in den 60ern noch den Paragraf, 175 war es, dass Liebe zwischen Männern,
Sex zwischen Männern war eine Straftat.
Da wurden Zehntausende verfolgt. Also auch da gab es eine Liberalisierung,
die viel mit 68 zu tun hat.
Und wenn man sich das jetzt mal so,
den Mikrokosmos der Rebellion mal so anguckt, so ein bisschen genauer,
dann sieht man, dass bestimmte Leute, die schon 68 dabei waren,
dann auch wieder in den 70er Jahren dabei waren.
Ich kann mich erinnern an einen sehr netten Menschen, der inzwischen gestorben
ist, Peter Rambausek, der kam aus der DDR,
sein Vater war ein Spanienkämpfer, ein hochverdienter Held der DDR und der flüchtete
aber nach West-Berlin und war dann mit Rudi Dutschke und anderen DDR-Leuten,
Bernd Rabell im SDS tätig und der tauchte auf in einer Anti-AKW-Gruppe,
die sich da in Gorleben betätigte gegen die Atomwiederaufarbeitungsanlage.
Und fand es unheimlich interessant da mit den jungen Leuten und wie die das
nun machen, war extrem angenehm.
Also hat uns nicht seine Erfahrung jetzt irgendwie aufgedrängt oder sich als
Besserwisser da aufgespielt.
Und wir müssen das so machen, haben wir ja schon 68 herausgefunden, dass es so nicht geht,
sondern der Teil dieser Gruppe war und ich glaube auch, dass eins die Leute,
die Ende der 60er Jahre rebelliert haben, aber auch dann in den 70er Jahren
verbindet, nämlich die Erfahrung, dass wenn man sich mit anderen zusammentut
und für seine Interessen eintritt.
Und auch mit Dingen, die man moralisch nicht verantworten kann und will,
bricht und was dagegen tut.
Dass die Erfahrungen, wenn sie dann auch noch erfolgreich sind,
eine unglaublich bereichernde Erfahrung sind.
Also das erlebt man nicht oft in seinem Leben, weil Rebellionen relativ selten sind.
Aber die Erfahrung, dass man was erreichen kann, ist Gold wert.
Also ich habe jetzt bei Recherchen mal mit einer Frau, Arbeiterkind aus Kreuzberg,
Marina Müller gesprochen, die das Georg von Rauchers mit besetzt hat.
Also es wurde 1961 von anarchistischen Jugendlichen besetzt und ist heute noch ein Jugendprojekt.
Und die sagte, das war so toll, wir haben gelernt, man kann was erreichen.
Man kann sich wehren und man kann was erreichen. Die haben erreicht,
dass ihr Haus dann irgendwann legalisiert wurde, dass sie nicht geräumt wurden
nach großen Auseinandersetzungen.
Also das Georg von Rauchhaus, was dann auch die Basis für den Rauchhaus-Song ist.
Ja, mittlerweile ist der Rauchhaus-Song viel bekannter als das Georg von Rauchhaus.
Also ich habe angerufen bei der Pressesprecherin des Bezirks Kreuzberg und habe
gefragt, was ist denn heute im Rauchhaus los?
Und da sagte sie, meinen Sie das Rauchhaus vom Rauchhaussong?
Wo ist denn das überhaupt? Ja, also das existiert, da sind irgendwie junge,
punkähnlich aussehende, nette Leute in so einem Wohnprojekt.
Ich habe alle ihre Podcasts noch nicht durchgehört.
Aber stimmt, der Rauchhaussong ist inzwischen ja die inoffizielle Nationalnämne
von Kreuzberg zumindest.
Nein, aber diese Erfahrung, dass man nicht alles hinnehmen muss und dass man
sich zusammenschließen kann und dass man,
wenn man zusammen für was kämmt, auch eine Gemeinsamkeit und ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl
erlebt, was man sonst nicht erlebt,
die ist schon ziemlich toll und die hinterlässt Leute, die auch in anderen Situationen,
wenn es darauf ankommt, eben auch den Mut haben und sagen, so, das ist das.
Geht hier nicht. Also wir müssen was dagegen machen. Dass es so eine breite,
Unterstützung zum Beispiel für Flüchtlinge gab. Ja.
Als diese sogenannte Flüchtlingswelle hier Deutschland heimgesucht hat,
liegt meiner Meinung nach auch daran, dass es eigentlich immer mehr Leute in
diesem Land gibt, die sagen,
nee, ich mache jetzt mal was, ich engagiere mich da, ich gucke mir das nicht
nur im Fernsehen an, ich finde irgendwas nicht richtig oder ich unterstütze dies und jenes.
Und so gesehen hat 68 eben, was so Zivilcourage angeht, sich einmischen,
Demokratisierung stand am Anfang eines langen Prozesses,
der dieses Land zu einem Land gemacht hat,
in dem viele leben wollen und was im Vergleich zu dem West-Berlin zum Beispiel
meiner Jugend, wo die verbitterten Kriegerwitwen einen irgendwie immer angepöbelt
haben, schon ganz schön sich verändert hat.
Und dazu war dann aber genau dieser Prozess Ende der 70er Jahre erstmal erforderlich,
den du schon angedeutet hast, mit diesem Treffen in Tunix.
Im Prinzip so die Reaktion auf diesen Zusammenbruch der Roten Armee Fraktion, dieses finalen Kampf.
Ja oder auch dieser ganzen Parteien, die für die Weltrevolution jetzt irgendwie
da gekämpft haben und Mao und Stalin rumgetragen haben. Das war Ende der 70er Jahre vorbei.
Genau, so und das hat aber auch so eine Taubheit zurückgelassen.
Bei manchen habe ich so den Eindruck, so wollen wir jetzt nicht weitermachen.
So, wir haben doch eigentlich Ziele,
die absolut sinnvoll und wichtig sind und das drückt sich halt aus sowohl in
dieser Friedensbewegung als auch in dieser ökologischen Bewegung,
die auch alle eng miteinander verzahnt sind.
Dann eben mit der aufkommenden Anti-AKW-Bewegung, die damit natürlich auch doppelt verzahnt ist.
Dieses Treffen in Tunix, das war ja so im Prinzip so ein Kristallisationspunkt,
wo Leute zusammengekommen sind, um genau das zu diskutieren.
Warst du da? Ja. Wie war das?
Ich habe damals auch die Zeitung mit einer Gruppe, also einer Anti-AKW-Gruppe
gemacht, ein Infobook, wo das Programm drin war und war dann deshalb auch da diese Tage. Das war...
Naja, wenn so ein paar tausend Leute zusammenkommen und alle erstaunt sind,
dass es so viele sind und alle neugierig zur Kenntnis nehmen,
dass in München aber schon ein Buchladenkollektiv und in West-Berlin ein Taxikollektiv
und da irgendwie ein Tischlerkollektiv arbeitet und ihre Erfahrungen machen,
anfangen miteinander zu reden.
Also das war so dieses Fiebrige in der Atmosphäre oder sowas.
Sehr energiereich habe ich das in Erinnerung. Und es war eben Schluss mit dem,
wie schafft das Polteat doch noch die Weltrevolution und einfach sich auf sich
selbst und auf seine unmittelbare Umgebung auch zu konzentrieren.
Dann ging es ja los in Kreuzberg es wurden Mietergruppen gegründet die sich
um die Stadt gekümmert haben,
und also diese Zuwendung auch mal was zu machen also von daher Tunix war ja
eigentlich eher ironisch gemeint Tunix wurde dann zu TuWatt jedenfalls von den
Leuten die da dann erschienen sind und.
Dass es so eine Zäsur war oder so ein wichtiges Ereignis ist eigentlich uns
erst im Nachhinein klar geworden.
Das ist aber glaube ich oft so, dass wenn man in einem Prozess mittendrin ist, dann weiß man nicht.
Chaos Computer Club, als dann irgendwann 1981 da an diesem berühmten Kommune
1 Tisch in der Wattstraße im Redaktionsgebäude der Taz, die ja gerade erst gegründet worden war,
da so ein paar Computerfreaks rumsaßen und mal so diskutiert haben,
was man denn so als Linke so mit Computer vielleicht anfangen könnte und was,
warum die ganzen linken Computer ganz entsetzlich finden und was man da so tun könnte.
Das war ja im Grunde, die da am Tisch saßen, wussten auch nicht,
dass irgendwie 30 Jahre später dann irgendwie Zehntausende zu irgendeinem Kongress
sich dann versammeln würden. Also du,
Hinterher bist du immer schlauer. Es ist auch eine Gefahr, dass man die Geschichte
von hinten immer begreift und dann sozusagen alles, was rauskommt als Zwangsflug, dann ansieht.
Aber in dem Prozess habe ich das persönlich damals nicht gesehen.
Was war denn so deine Büro mit dem Club, mit dem CCC? Hast du das früh kennengelernt?
Ich habe das aber, das liegt nur an so biografischen Zufälligkeiten.
Ich bin nach Hamburg gezogen irgendwann,
so circa 1984 und kannte so eine Musikerin, Annette Humpe,
Sängerin Ideal und die sagte, also wenn du nach Hamburg ziehst,
dann musst du unbedingt meinen Freund Peter Glaser kennenlernen.
Und dann bin ich nach Hamburg gezogen und habe mich dann da bei Peter Glaser
angemeldet und der wohnte auf dem Kiez in St.
Pauli und hatte einen Commodore 64 und schrieb da so lustige Programme,
Poetronik, so ein Dichtprogramm oder spielte irgendwelche merkwürdigen Spiele und,
Kam dann, also war da glaube ich noch nicht in Kontakt, aber kam dann relativ
schnell mit dem Club in Kontakt.
Wir wohnten dann in einer Wohngemeinschaft in Eimsbüttel, nicht weit in der
Schwenkestraße unten im Keller, zwischen riesigen Stapeln von dem damaligen
Computerdruckpapier und irgendwelcher Hardware.
Lief Wau rum und da gab es diese Treffen und so. Und von daher...
Da hast du auch gewohnt.
Nee, um die Ecke haben wir ein bisschen geholt.
Aber ich finde auch da, wenn man jemanden wie Wau gekannt hat,
natürlich war vieles von dem, was der gedacht hat und die Ideen,
mit denen er ankam oder auch Leute, die er kannte, hatte was mit den 60er Jahren zu tun.
Also eher mit so einem Hippie, hier Werner Pieper, Hippies auf dem Land,
als jetzt irgendwie Metropolenkämpfer in West-Berlin.
Aber auch das im Club ist im Grunde, der Club hat das gemacht,
was alle, die mal irgendwann rebellieren machen, er hat nämlich,
die Leute haben sich hingesetzt und gesagt, warum ist denn das so?
Muss das so sein? Also was in Frage stellen, kritisch nachdenken,
was überprüfen, könnte man nicht irgendwas besser machen oder so das hat der
Klub in seinem Feld dann finde ich sehr gut.
Ja praktiziert und vorangetrieben und das haben aber auch eben in vielen anderen
Bereichen andere getan, von daher gehört der Klub ob er es nun will oder nicht aber irgendwie ist,
wahrscheinlich auch die Meinungen sind geteilter gehört der Klub für mich zu
diesem großen Aufbruch der aus den 60ern Jahren dazu.
Und noch dazu kenne ich schon,
in meinen Hamburger Zeiten, Klaus Schleisig, der damals bei diesem historischen
Treffen auch dabei war, er hat glaube ich den Text geschrieben,
wie er mir immer gesagt hat.
Diese, ich weiß nicht, waren 17 Zeilen in der Taz.
Ja, dieses Tuvat.txt halt.
Richtig. Und der kam ja, der war ja lange in den USA und hatte da mit irgendwelchen,
ja so Hacker, hießen sie ja noch gar nicht, aber mit Computerfreaks Kontakt
gehabt und war für mich so eine Personifizierung eines amerikanischen Hippies.
Auch da kamen diese kulturellen Einflüsse. Aber da ja nie sozusagen was plötzlich
irgendwie aus der Kiste springt und geboren wird und so ist und keine Wurzeln hat,
war es für mich auch völlig logisch, dass sozusagen der Club auf diesem Grund
irgendwie aufbaut und eigentlich in vielen Punkten auch mit dem Sachen in Frage zu stellen,
nachzufragen, zu diskutieren, der auch dem treu geblieben ist.
Warholand war ja im Prinzip die prägende Figur des frühen CCC.
Er war schuld, kann man sagen. Er war bei dem Treffen dabei und er hat dann
eigentlich auch diese Idee mit, jetzt müsste man mal den Chaos Computer gründen
oder der ist jetzt gegründet in den Raum getragen.
Was dann jetzt noch so zwei, drei Jahre dauerte, bis sich das wirklich so final
manifestierte, aber ja dann, wie wir alle wissen, dann doch extrem losging.
Du bist ja auch jemand, der dann über eine längere Zeit so on-off begleitet hat.
Wie hast du ihn da erlebt?
Was ist so dein Eindruck? Wie seine Verbundenheit mit dieser politischen Zeit tatsächlich war?
Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere und weil wir vorhin über die RAF gesprochen
haben, es gab ja eine Organisation, nämlich die Rote Hilfe, die RAF gefangen
unterstützt hat und für die Geld gesammelt hat.
Und wenn ich das richtig erinnere, dann hat Wau in Marburg in einem Buch verzeichnet,
wer wie viel für die Rote Hilfe gespendet hat.
Das heißt also, Wau kam selbst aus dieser radikalen politischen Bewegung,
hat sich aber aus der dann herausentwickelt und so über die Jahre, also,
Ich finde, dass Wau heute ein bisschen zu sehr mystifiziert wird,
beziehungsweise er hat ganz tolle und starke Seiten, also sein unabhängiges Denken,
Sachen in Frage zu stellen und irgendwie weiterzudenken und selbst wenn es irgendwie
erstmal noch nicht so geläufig war, irgendwie einfach immer da weiterzumachen
und zu diskutieren und das ist wunderbar.
Aber er hat, wie ein paar andere der Kerngruppe von Chaos Computer Club,
sozial und im Umgang, im Zwischenmenschlichen schon gewisse Defizite gehabt.
Surprise. Da lachst du so, aber so eine gewisse Empathiearmut oder auch irgendwie
so eine schwach ausgeprägte Fähigkeiten,
so Stimmungen zwischen Menschen mitzubekommen und dann auch darauf zu reagieren,
das fand ich schon, aber nicht nur bei ihm.
Ja, da ist ja diese ganze Bewegung, auch so eine eigene Therapiegruppe, nicht selten gewesen.
Wenn das so funktioniert, super.
Ja, es funktioniert auf seine Art natürlich schon. Das hat natürlich so ein
bisschen so seine Härten, aber es sind ja auch Leute, die ja dann auch,
ich will das jetzt nicht so generalisieren, aber sagen wir mal so ein grundautistisches
Verhalten, das spürt man schon in verschiedensten Abstufungen,
ist aber auch natürlich ein bisschen Grund für diese Art Diskurs,
die halt so dann auch geführt wird.
Also das ist ja sozusagen auch so dieses enorm am Thema,
am Inhalt, am logischen Denken, sich abarbeiten und darüber das zu machen und
dann eben vielleicht auch davon zu profitieren,
dass man in dem Moment gar nicht so sehr auf die Gepflogenheiten etc.
Eingeht und sich dadurch vielleicht unter Umständen inhaltlich bremsen muss.
Das hat so seine Abstufung.
Aber erzähl ruhig noch ein bisschen weiter.
Wie du das wahrgenommen hast. aber politisch gesehen finde ich ja dann wieder, dass,
Wenn man sich anschaut, dass heutzutage in den großen Auseinandersetzungen um
informationelle Selbstbestimmung, um im Kampf gegen die totale Überwachung und Massensüberwachung,
in den Auseinandersetzungen darüber,
ob Julian Assange noch 20 Jahre in der äquatorianischen Botschaft in London
sitzt oder Edward Snowden in Moskau irgendwann begraben wird,
Und da spielen ja einzelne Leute zumindest aus dem Klub oder aus dem Umfeld
des Klubs heute eine wichtige Rolle.
Und von daher zeigt mir, dass der Klub nicht nur 81 oder die Gruppe,
die dann ein paar Jahre später den Klub gegründet hat.
Dass die nicht nur sozusagen damals in den politischen Auseinandersetzungen
ziemlich weit vorne waren und Fragen damals adressiert waren.
Also zum Beispiel dieser Slogan des Clubs, den finde ich heute noch immer super,
die privaten Daten schützen, öffentliche Nutzen.
Und das waren ja abrangatistische Ideen, genauso wie wenn Helke Sander sich
1968 auf der Delegierten Konferenz des SDS hinstellt und sagt,
also jetzt ist mal Schluss hier mit den Pachas und jetzt wird mal hier die Kindererziehung
halbe halbe gemacht und so.
Dann ist das ein Gedanke, das haben die ganzen Männer, was will die denn?
Aber er war völlig richtig, in diese Richtung geht es. Und so hat der Club auch
bestimmte Ideen aufgewacht und ist eben heute noch, da sind ja diese Auseinandersinnungen
noch wichtiger geworden oder werden immer wichtiger.
Und werden auch immer noch unter demselben Titel geführt.
Aber wenn da noch Leute vom Club dabei sind, ist doch super.
Das zeigt doch nur, dass sozusagen da eine Tradition des freiheitlichen Denkens,
des Hinterfragens, des, wenn man was nicht richtig findet, dass man auch was
dagegen tut, dass die Tradition da lebt.
Abgesehen vom CCC, der ja dann auch ein bisschen später in der Folge war,
gab es ja dann auch noch eine unmittelbarere Folge, nämlich so diese Erkenntnis
dieser Aufbruchsszene,
wir brauchen auch unsere eigenen Medien immer gegen Springer protestieren,
das ist so das eine, aber wenn wir es irgendwie besser machen wollen,
dann müssen wir da sozusagen auch selber uns unabhängig aufstellen,
was ja dann zur Gründung der Tageszeitung geführt hat.
Und gleich vorwegzunehmen natürlich auch diese politische Marsch durch die Institutionen
der dann auch ausgerufen wurde der dann so aus der Friedensbewegung und der
Ökologie Bewegung heraus eben die Grüne,
das Grüne Projekt gestartet hat,
vielleicht erstmal so die Taz,
Taz gibt es ja auch noch als.
Genossenschaft ist die Taz sicherer als der Sprenger Verlag oder Spiegel.
Also um die Taz muss man mit Zukunft der Taz muss man sich ja keine Gedanken mehr machen.
Na, inhaltlich schon.
Allerdings. Das wollte ich hier erst mal vermeiden, diese Frage.
Die Taz innerlich zu beurteilen. Nein, aber die Taz war eben auch so ein Versuch,
von Leuten, auch die keine Ahnung hatten. Das finde ich übrigens interessant.
Danikon Bendit sagt immer, wenn es um die Meditanz und die Radikalität der 68er
geht, die wäre ja furchtbar gewesen damals,
dann sagt Danikon Bendit immer, aber wenn wir schon mit einem kompromissreifen
Vorschlag angekommen wären, dann wäre doch gar nichts passiert.
Also man muss einfach auch mal radikal sein, losmarschieren,
radikale Forderungen stellen, damit sich überhaupt irgendwas bewegt,
damit man auch irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit bekommt.
Und dann, finde ich, gehört eine gewisse Naivität auch, also ich habe das manchmal
so genannt, die Arroganz der Adoleszenz.
Wenn man so 23 ist zum Beispiel, oder so in seinen Zwanzigern,
dann hat man wenig Angst, man hat wenig Risikobewusstsein und man.
Kommt leicht in so ein Gefühl, wir blicken durch, die anderen sind alle Idioten
und so und das machen wir mal.
Und mit diesem Bewusstsein kann man überhaupt bestimmte Dinge nur tun,
denn damals die Leute, die sich zusammengetan haben, um eine Tageszeitung zu gründen,
wir wussten, oder Spiegel-Redakteurten haben gesagt, man braucht eine Million
Mark, damals irrsinnig viel Geld.
Ja, woher sind wir eine Million Mark? Hatten wir natürlich nicht.
Dann sagten andere, die schon als Journalisten arbeiteten, ja,
ihr seid doch alles Amateure, stimmt das?
Wir hatten, glaube ich, drei Leute, die schon mal eine Tageszeitung von innen gesendet haben.
Der andere war Taxifahrer, sozial, irgendwie Berufsrevolutionäre, sonst wer.
Und mit so einer Truppe anzutreten, also ohne Geld, ohne Ahnung,
und zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt mal. Ist eine gute Idee.
Irgendwie liegt das auf der Hand. Muss sein.
Und das hätte man mit, wenn man 40 wäre, wahrscheinlich nicht so gemacht.
Obwohl Christian Ströbele war damals glaube ich 40.
Der war da dabei. Und ja, also es ist diese alternative Gründerzeit,
auch mit den Grünen, das war ja so einfach, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Und das finde ich auch eine sehr erfrischende Erfahrung.
Wenn ich daran zurückdenke, wenn wir auf die ganzen Kassandras und Bedenkenträger
gehört hätten damals, dann hätten wir doch nie irgendwas gemacht.
Da gab es immer, das funktioniert nicht, das ist zu teuer, das muss man anders machen.
Wir haben einfach das gemacht. Anders als die 68er.
Die 68er waren meiner Meinung nach sehr auf die Theorie fixiert und wollten
sozusagen ein ganz komplexes theoretisches Gebäude errichten,
wie man die Gesellschaft umwälzt und wie sie alle emanzipieren können.
Wir haben eigentlich eher so pragmatisch gesagt, naja, linke Tageszeitungen,
die Linken wollen miteinander kommunizieren, wollen wissen, was los ist,
also machen wir doch einfach eine.
Und dass die dann heute so erfolgreich ist, freut mich immer noch.
Und ich finde sie natürlich ein bisschen zu mainstreamig und ein bisschen zu
wenig radikal und unkonventionell.
Aber auf der anderen Seite kann ich ja jetzt nicht so als Alter den Jungschen
vorschreiben, was sie für eine Zeitung machen sollen.
Hast du auch mitgewirkt bei der Taz?
Ja, ich war Gründungsmitglied damals.
Du warst auch Gründungsmitglied.
Ja, ich war in dieser Berliner Taz-Initiative und war dann in der Ökologieredaktion.
Und da bin ich auch noch immer ein bisschen stolz drauf.
Wir haben damals Ökologieredaktion der Taz, wir haben die ganzen Themen,
das hieß damals nicht Renewables, also Energien, sondern alternative Energien.
Wir haben Seiten produziert, Windradentfind und Windenergie und Erdwärme,
also Geothermie. Wir haben eigentlich schon diese ganzen Dinge,
die dann jetzt mühsam so durchgesetzt werden, haben wir damals propagiert.
Und dann natürlich die Auseinandersetzung oder der Kampf gegen die Atomanlagen.
Und das war in der Taz auch so.
Da wurden halt bestimmte Themen, also Feminismus, Ökologie, dann so internationales,
also dritte Welt und was heute Fairtrade ist vielleicht.
Und dann noch das alternative Leben, anders arbeiten.
Das waren unsere vier inhaltlichen Säulen, die haben wir ganz bewusst zugesetzt,
weil wir annahmen, dass das die Themen sind, die weitertragen die nächsten Jahre. Und das war auch so.
Es ist kein persönlicher Verdienst von mir oder irgendjemandem.
Wir waren einfach sozusagen, das war vielleicht unsere Mission.
Das sollten wir mal machen.
Aber es ist schon so, dass ich...
Mir nicht, also wenn ich jetzt mal in einer kommunistischen Partei dann Mao
Zedong und Pol Pot und Stalin und sowas hoch hätte, dann musste ich mir heute
Vorwürfe machen und denke, oh Gott, was habe ich damals für einen Unsinn gedacht.
Zum Glück war ich mir immer in dieser liberalen, anarchistischen,
libertären Strömung, Spontis hießen sie damals,
drin und wir empfinden, ich müssen uns keine großen Vorwürfe machen,
also wir müssen uns vielleicht eher so den Vorwürfen machen,
dass wir dann doch uns zu sehr angepasst haben oder zu sehr oder zu schnell
in diese Gesellschaft integriert haben.
Was ich zum Beispiel bei den Grünen heute sehe, also wenn heute so Grüne da auftreten,
dann sind die mir zu angepasst und staatstragend und zu sehr auf ihre persönlichen
Ambitionen und Karrieren dann fixiert.
Jetzt hast du so ein bisschen nebenbei noch so zwei Begriffe mal fallen lassen in den letzten Minuten,
vor einer halben Stunde, die eigentlich auch immer wieder vorkommen und die
auch keiner so richtig mit Leben füllen kann, nämlich Sponti und vorher schon
auch den Begriff der außerparlamentarischen Opposition.
Stehen auch so ein bisschen in Verbindung, oder?
Naja, APO oder Außerparamentarische Opposition war der Begriff für die Studentenbewegung in den 60er Jahren.
Den haben sich die Studenten damals allerdings nicht selber gegeben,
sondern den haben sich irgendwelche Journalisten ausgedacht und dann hat der sich verfestigt.
Und der Begriff Spontis oder Spontaneisten kam eigentlich wesentlich später hoch.
Der kam aus Italien damals.
Es gab so Leute, Toni Negri, der ist heute noch berühmt, ein Professor aus Padua, die haben,
So versucht aus dem Marxismus noch irgendwie eine aktuelle emanzipative Ideologie
zu formen und sind dann auf so Ideen gekommen,
dass also die Jugendlichen und Marginalisierten und die Frauen und sonstigen
Minderheiten irgendwann den Aufstand machen würden.
Nicht mehr das Polterat, die Arbeiterklasse und sie haben an die Spontanität auch von.
Arbeiteraufständen und überhaupt irgendwelchen Rebellionen darauf gesetzt und
von den Spontanisten aus Italien kam dann dieses Wort Spontis,
wurde dann Sponti und kam nach Deutschland.
Es waren eigentlich diejenigen, die dann in Tunix sich versammelt haben, waren die Leute,
die in Stadtteilgruppen gegangen waren oder die Frauenzentren gegründet hatten,
also jetzt nicht eine Kaderpartei und Weltrevolution und all sowas,
sondern die in den sozialen Bereichen, in denen sie selbst drin waren,
interveniert haben und versucht haben, da irgendwas voranzubringen und Danikon
Wendet war immer der Spontifex Maximus,
der oder der bekannteste von ihnen, aber im Grunde hatte das auch so eine also
wir waren eben keine Marxisten wir waren keine Leninisten wir wollten mit diesen,
traditionellen Sozialismus, auch mit dem realen Sozialismus,
nichts zu tun haben, sondern uns schwebte eine freie Gesellschaft vor,
aber eine Gesellschaft, in der nicht das Geld das ist, was zählt,
in der nicht der Kapitalismus alles bestimmt, sondern in der es,
demokratisch und gerecht dazu geht.
Und es war ein bisschen sozusagen auch so eine Alternative zu diesen K-Gruppen.
Die sich eigentlich so als Fallout aus dieser ganzen Zeit absolut,
die fanden wir furchtbar dann gleich wieder eine Partei und dann haben die auch so in die Kostümm,
Kiste der Arbeiterbewegung gegriffen und dann irgendwie so mit Schiebermütze
und so Berlin 20er Jahre Alexanderplatz mäßig dann vor ein Fabrik sich gestellt,
aber leider dann wenig Interesse gefunden mit ihren Flugblättern.
Nee, das fanden wir, also diese Art von Marxismus fanden wir furchtbar.
Und die haben uns natürlich dann wieder beschimpft, irgendwie als Kleinbürger
und strategisch und sonst was alles.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht war der sozusagen die mit mehr Humor und am Ende auch
mehr auf die Reihe bekommen haben.
Ja, natürlich war der Einfluss, den wir ausgeübt haben auf die Gesellschaft.
Und zwar, ich sage es nochmal, 70er Jahre Ökologiebewegung und Frauenbewegung.
Der war wesentlich größer als jetzt irgendeine kommunistische Kleinpartei,
die Enver Hoca in Albanien ganz super fand und sozusagen den Rest der Welt nach
dem großen Führer Enver Hoca dann modellieren wollte.
Diese Führerverliebtheit, die wollte so recht nicht nachlassen.
Ja, aber das war eben, die Spontis waren, zeichnen sich dadurch aus,
dass auch die eigenen Autoritäten, also Dani wurde dann immer als Promi angegriffen,
dass er so Autoritäten nicht anerkannt hat.
Mhm.
Und ich habe gerade so locker vom Bauch weg mal gesagt, ihr hattet mehr Humor.
Ich weiß nicht, spielt der Humor da eine Rolle?
Manches wirkt ja auch sehr verbissen. Dieser ganze Gesellschaftskampf und alles
ist böse und Springerpresse hier und der böse Staat und Terror und so.
Politik ist ja nun mal eine ernste Sache.
Ich kenne Unterhaltung.
Wenn man Politik als Unterhaltung haben will, dann kriegt man Donald Trump. Kann man auch wollen.
Aber Politik ist eine ernste Sache.
Es gab dann immer so Spontiklosprüche und Witze.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir besonders witzig waren. Wir waren so ein bisschen kulturfeindlich
im Nachhinein betrachtet.
Also die Ästhetik und so hat uns nicht so interessiert und Inhalt war wichtig
und auch so dann irgendwelche bürgerliche Kunst, also sozusagen das Stichwort,
wenn man was aburteilen wollte, war immer bürgerlich, bürgerliche Kultur,
bürgerliche Kunst und so.
Interessiert uns alles nicht. Also da waren wir schon ein bisschen borniert,
aber ja doch eine gewisse Selbstironie hatten wir auch.
Aber die hatten ja auch schon die Studenten, wenn sie gesagt haben,
wir sind eine kleine radikale Minderheit und so haben wir uns eigentlich auch gefühlt damals.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das so aufbringe, warum mir das so wichtig ist,
aber ich sehe es ja jetzt, wenn ich mal so ein bisschen zurückschaue und gucke,
wer sonst noch so diesen kritischen Blick und auch kulturell so sozusagen so
seine Duftmarken hinterlassen hat.
Fallen mir halt Leute ein, wie Christoph Schlingensief, der ähm,
vielleicht jetzt auch noch nicht unbedingt mit Humor geglänzt hat,
aber allein dessen Projekte schon so einen Witz hatten und dadurch ja auch so
ein katalytisches Element in die Diskussion bringt.
Aber ich fand also, Schlingensief kam aus der Kunst oder Kultur und hat in dieser Sphäre auch agiert.
Es gab immer, jetzt angefangen von der Kommune 1 und deren Happenings,
bis heute gibt es sozusagen so ein Spaßgerier, Abteilung oder Leute, die sagen,
hat keinen Sinn, nur so nüchterne Aufklärung zu machen, sondern wir müssen irgendwie
etwas machen, wo die Leute vielleicht ins Überlegen kommen oder wo wir die Lacher
auf unserer Seite haben.
Ich hatte ja im CRE auch schon ein schönes, langes Gespräch mit der Hedonistischen
Internationale und so heute Zentrum für politische Schönheit bringt ja auch die ganze Diskussion.
Auch so ein bisschen kritisch, weil die so ein elitärer Gunstverein sind.
Aber ich will nochmal sagen, also die Kommune 1, da gab es mal ein Staatsbegebnis für Paul Löbe,
der war ein Reichstagsabgeordneter in West-Berlin und da sind die dann angetreten
und sind mit einem Sarg aufmarschiert vom Rathaus Schönemann und irgendwann ging,
und Andreas Bader zum Beispiel schleppte dann den Sarg auch mit,
Und irgendwann ging oben der Deckel auf und der Kunzelmann von der Kommune 1
in so einer Art Nachthemd stand auf,
turnte da oben rum und warf irgendwelche Flugblätter dann aus diesem Sarg raus.
Das ist ja natürlich irgendwie Polizei und irgendwie gesagt Beschlagnahmt und ganz schlimm.
Und solche Aktionen gab es immer. Zum Beispiel die letzte, auf die ich gestoßen
bin, die finde ich auch wunderbar.
1981, als es in Westberlin eine große Hausbesetzerbewegung gab.
Da gab es ein besetztes Haus, zwei nebeneinander, die heute auch noch von den
damaligen Besetzern bewohnt sind, in der Potsdamer Straße. der Botztommer Straße 157 159.
Da sollte dann mal der Papst, ich glaube damals war es Paul Johannes,
nach Deutschland kommen. Und es gab großes Tralala mit Papstbesuch.
Und dann überlegten die sich so im Suff oder auch nicht im Suff,
lass uns doch einen Gegenpapst ausrufen.
In der Geschichte gab es ja viele Gegenpäpste. Wenn um den Kaiser der Papst
nicht passt, gab es einen Gegenpapst, der dann den Kaiser gekrönt hat und so weiter.
Und dann gab es drei Päpste und dann musste das auch erst wieder geklärt werden.
Und dann gab es so einen Punk da, Etzer, und dann wurde Etzer zum Gegenpapst gemacht.
So eine Tonsur mit so einem Kreuz um den Kopf, imrasiert,
dann so eine Soutane besorgt und schon zogen 25, 30 Hausbesetzer hinter Etzer,
dem Gegenpapst, zum Winterfeldmarkt und der Gegenpapst segnete da das Gemüse
und die Gläubigen fielen von ihm auf die Knie.
Und das war natürlich auch eigentlich eine Quatschaktion.
Aber sowas, das macht man einfach, um selber Spaß zu haben, aber auch um Leute
zu erstaunen oder vielleicht mal zum Nachdenken zu bringen und sowas gab und
gibt es zum Glück immer, dass sich.
Jetzt jemand hinsetzt und sagt, ach nicht schon wieder nur so ein Flugblatt
allein und so, sondern lass uns doch mal irgendein Straßentheater oder irgendwas machen.
Und das ist eine sozusagen der kontinuierlichen Elemente, die durch all diese
Generationen von Rebellen und Bewegungen und so durchgehen.
Die Grünen sind ja nun vorhin schon erwähnt der andere Fallout aus dieser Zeit.
Man kann ja nicht sagen, dass sie nichts bewirkt hätten.
Ne, Mülltrennung ist ganz gut hier. Was haben sie noch?
Ich finde, sie haben schon einen extremen Wandel hervorgebracht.
Ich meine, zunächst einmal sind sie ja auch erstmal so im 68er-Style im Bundestag
zusammengeschrien worden für ein paar Jahre, während sie da strickend herumsassen.
Also für mich so, ich bin ja so Baujahr 67, für mich haben da so die 80er-Jahre
schon so, das war so die prägende Phase,
wo ich so um mich herum geschaut habe, was machen eigentlich die anderen,
da waren die Grünen natürlich schon ein interessanter Katalysator,
an dem sich dann doch so einiges abgeregnet hat und man hat halt,
also viele Leute haben da wirklich dann auch die Maske,
heruntergelassen und man merkte halt einfach, okay, also deren Anliegen,
die haben so viel Relevanz, dass alle da so sehr drauf reinhauen,
ja, also so steil gehen irgendwie aufgrund ihrer Thesen, dann muss da halt auch
was dran sein und haben für meinen Geschmack halt erheblich dazu beigetragen,
dass eben diese Idee der, zumindest der ökologischen,
Bewegung, aber sicherlich auch der Friedensbewegung,
dass das Auftrieb bekommen hat.
Also ich habe jetzt,
gesäufzt oder gestöhnt nicht über die Grünen der 80er, also über die heutigen Grünen.
Ja gut, aber die ist meiner Meinung nach auch ein anderes Thema.
Nein, nein, die waren, aber das war eigentlich auch unser politisches Modell.
Wir haben immer gesagt, bei der Gründung der Grünen, ich war auch mal,
hatte die Mitgliedsnummer 300 der alternativen Liste, das war so der Westberliner
Vorläufer, war da auch mal kurz paar Jahre Mitglied.
Und wir haben ja damals gesagt, Okay, Stand und Spielbein.
Es braucht, um politische Veränderungen durchzusetzen, auf der einen Seite eine
soziale Bewegung, die Aktionen macht, Demos macht, die einfach Thema in die
Öffentlichkeit macht, Druck macht.
Und dann braucht es aber eine Truppe im Parlament oder eine Fraktion,
die versucht, die Forderungen, die von der APO da in dem Fall kommen,
dann auch in Gesetze umzusetzen oder Koalitionen zu bilden oder bestimmte,
reformistisch dann bestimmte Ziele zu erreichen.
Und dieses Modell sehe ich auch heute noch für das Richtige an.
Parteien sind strukturell nicht in der Lage, neue Ideen zu entwickeln.
Die neuen Ideen kommen immer von außerhalb der Parteien, so aus sozialen Milieus, gerne auch am Rande.
Und aber diese Ideen damit sie nicht völlig verpuffen müssen ja irgendwie dann
weiter in die Gesellschaft getragen werden, in den etablierten Strukturen irgendwie
auch verankert werden und das ist dann die Aufgabe,
einer Partei wie die Grünen das zu tun.
Wenn die sich so weit von allen ausmantarischen Milieus wegbewegt und zu so einem.
Trutschigen Karrieristenverein dann degeneriert, dann haben sie eigentlich sozusagen
ihre Aufgabe verfehlt, aber diese Vorstellung, dass man auch in den Parlamenten,
was braucht es ja gerade,
die Lehre auch aus der RAF, also man kann nicht einfach einen Bürgerkrieg anfangen,
also moralisch und politisch klappt es sowieso nicht,
sondern man muss sich schon die Mühe machen, dann auch Mehrheiten zu erreichen
und Leute zu überzeugen und dann muss man eben versuchen in diesem parlamentarischen System,
außer es wird faschistisch, dann gibt es vielleicht so ein Widerstandsrecht,
aber Aber ansonsten hat man verdammt die Pflicht und Schuldigkeit,
seine Dinge, seine Ideen zu begründen und versuchen, die politisch durchzusetzen.
Und da kommt die Partei ins Spiel.
Wie lange denkst du, hat das, oder was ist so, das Erbe dieser Bewegung,
also dieser politischen, konkreten politischen Bewegung?
Also Erbe in dem Sinn von Hinterlassenschaft, da hat diese Bewegung aus den
60er Jahren eben im Grunde diese Gesellschaft, so wie sie heute ist,
wesentlich strukturiert.
Mit den Werten von Toleranz gegenüber sexuellen Minderheiten,
gegenüber rassischen Minderheiten, gegenüber allen möglichen.
Das ist sehr gewichtig.
Die Idee der Gleichheit, dann auch direkte Demokratie, Partizipation.
Da war diese Bewegung ungeheuer wichtig.
Einzelne Ausfälle wie die Voltarische Weltrevolution,
die sind zum Glück waren nicht realistisch oder haben sich nicht durchgesetzt
aber die meine These ist schon die dass die 68er und alle die danach kamen,
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und dann auch später das ganz Deutschland,
zu einem.
Vergleichsweise liberalen Land gemacht haben, in dem man ganz gut leben kann,
auch wenn man sehr individualistisch ist und irgendwie Vorstellungen hat,
die jetzt nicht der Mainstream entsprechen,
ist es doch heute wesentlich besser, als wenn du so einer konformen Gesellschaft,
die alle Minderheiten ausgrenzt und vielleicht noch gar kriminalisiert,
dich in der leben musst.
Also von daher habe ich ein positives Fazit
von 68 in dem was
erreicht wurde oder was die Ideen verändert haben und als Akteur oder als jemand
der bei der Gründung der Taz beteiligt war und also ja eigentlich seit den 60er
Jahren politisch in Gruppen aktiv war für mich persönlich und die allermeisten
Leute die ich erlebt habe,
ist das Erlebnis, dass man auch was erreichen kann
oder dass man auch Ideen haben kann die dann irgendwie sich
umsetzen also wie die ökologischen Ideen ist
natürlich toll weil man nicht das Gefühl hat man ist völlig ohnmächtig irgendwelchen
Kräften unterworfen und kann nichts machen und versteht nichts also die subjektive
Seite ist mindestens ebenso positiv wie die,
objektive Seite was seit den 60er Jahren sich verändert hat.
Und wenn du dann so einen Alexander Dobrindt von der CSU hörst,
wie er die 68er so als neues oder altes Feindbild aus der Hosentasche holt und
meint, das wäre ja so ein liberaler Mainstream hier und das müsste ja mal ein Rollback.
Also die 68er waren ja schon immer umstritten und angefeindet,
von daher ist es sozusagen Ehrensache, dass auch irgendein Dödel wie Dobrindt
dann nochmal sein München versucht an den 68ern zu kühlen.
Aber ich finde, das ist insofern unsinnig. Der Herr Dobrindt hat ja gesagt,
es bedarf einer konservativen Revolution.
Und das zeigt, das sage ich jetzt mal als Historiker, dass er nichts von Geschichte verstanden hat.
Denn Revolutionen, die kann man nicht so ausrufen. So, jetzt machen wir mal eine Revolution.
Ich meine, das hat man ja gesehen in den 70er Jahren, als die selbsternannten
Arbeiterführer dann versucht haben, die Revolution vorzubereiten oder zu machen.
Die eignen sich, auch Rebellionen oder Revolten eignen sich oft,
wenn niemand damit rechnet oder gerade dann besonders gerne.
Bevor die 68er, dann Mitte der 60er losmarschiert waren, war der Tenor unter
den westdeutschen Soziologen, die angepasste Generation, apathisch,
unpolitisch, völliger Nonsens.
Es kam ganz anders. Also von daher ist diese Vorstellung, man müsste jetzt eine
konservative Revolution ausrufen, ist Unsinn.
Ich meine, es gibt immer eben seit den 60er Jahren Politiker,
die glauben, sie können bei ihren Anhängern damit punkten, wenn sie so irgendwelche 68er,
die ja meistens, wirklich 68er sind ja schon gestorben oder im betagten Alter,
wenn sie auf den ein bisschen rumhacken.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach Unsinn.
Guido Westerwelle hat das auch besonders gerne gemacht, aber ihr als schwuler
Außenminister eigentlich sollte in den 68ern dankbar gewesen sein,
weil 1950 wäre er ja kein Außenminister geworden.
Egal, also diese Auseinandersetzung halte ich eigentlich für ein bisschen unsinnig.
Ich finde es interessant und da wird aber wenig geforscht.
Die Soziologen sollten sich doch mal angucken, wie entstehen denn jetzt solche
Bewegungen, die dann auch das Klima einer Gesellschaft und einer Gesellschaft prägen.
Was sind das für Leute irgendwie und wie geht es so im Einzelnen?
Das würde mich jetzt als Historiker interessieren und jetzt geht es ja darum,
50 Jahre 68, Also die genuinen 68er sind in ihren späten 70ern, 80ern.
Als Historiker muss ich jetzt rumlaufen und die alle nochmal befragen und sozusagen
die Quellen sichern und die Informationen sichern, damit man später nochmal
darüber reflektieren kann.
Wobei ich gestern in der Berliner Zeitung so einen Artikel gelesen habe über
68 und dachte, oh Gott, die hat ja nichts verstanden.
Da wurden dann Sachen so völlig falsch bewährt, dass plötzlich Griechenland,
die Diktatur in Griechenland, das große Thema der 68 war totaler Mumpitz.
Dann habe ich mal nachgelesen, das ist eine junge Frau, die in Sachsen-Anhalt
geboren ist. Ja, my goodness.
Es ist wahnsinnig schwierig, glaube ich, wenn man nicht dabei war,
zu vermeiden, dass man Sachen auch völlig falsch einschätzt oder irgendwas abschreibt,
was man selber nicht verstanden hat und so.
Also von daher sehe ich es eigentlich so ein bisschen als meine Aufgabe und
deshalb habe ich auch so ein Buch darüber geschrieben, über die Rebellionen
in Berlin, meiner Heimatstadt.
Ja eigentlich mal sozusagen die Quellen zu sichern,
zu klären, was ist wann passiert, was hat wer in Erinnerung,
was hat wer gesagt und dann kann man sich irgendwann eben so mit dieser Zeit auseinandersetzen.
Tja und wie wertest du jetzt so die,
Die Beständigkeit dieser Veränderung, ich meine jetzt haben wir mit der AfD
und so einem Wählerrechtsruck, weiß ja keiner so richtig, ist das jetzt hier
wieder nur so eine Sinuswelle,
die aufmuckt oder wird jetzt hier gerade der große Rollback eingeleitet?
Schwierige Frage. Also ich kann mich noch sehr gut daran erinnern,
dass ich eigentlich noch so in den 70er Jahren oder bis in die 80er Jahren gedacht habe,
die Deutschen, und das hängt auch mit dem Nazi-Erbe zusammen, sind ein Volk.
Wenn es wirtschaftlich hart auf hart kommt, oder wenn die Deutschen unter Druck
geraten, gehen sie immer nach rechts, nie nach links.
Und dann ist es aber nicht passiert. Dann war eigentlich doch,
kann man sagen, eigentlich so seit den 60er Jahren, exekutiert durch CDU-Politiker
wie Helmut Kohl oder Angela Merkel,
sind dann bestimmte Ideen aus den 60er Jahren auch mainstream geworden und dann
politisch umgesetzt worden.
Es ging also nach meinem Wertesystem oder nach meinem politischen Denken durchaus voran.
Es dauert immer viel zu lange und man hätte schon in ökologischen Fragen eigentlich
schon vor 30 Jahren irgendwie den Hebel versuchen müssen umzulegen und alternative Energien zu machen.
Aber es geht doch irgendwie voran.
Und nicht nur, wenn man sich die AfD in Deutschland anguckt,
sondern wenn man sich diese ganzen verschwitzten, schnappstrinkenden osteuropäischen
Volkstribunen anguckt, in Polen und Tschechien und wo auch immer.
Und wenn man sich Donald Trump anguckt, dann fragt man sich schon,
ob denn so diese schöne Idee der Aufklärung alles wird immer besser und menschlicher
und zivilisierter und gerechter und so, ob diese Idee nicht gleich falsch ist und ob es nicht.
Historische Perioden gibt, wie sagen wir auch die 20er Jahre,
wo es in Deutschland eine Demokratie gab und dann kamen eben die Nazis.
Ob es nicht ganz bösartige Rückschritte auch geben kann.
Und bei der Frage bin ich nicht entschieden im Augenblick.
Das ist noch zu früh, um das abzuschätzen, ob sowas wie die AfD,
die kann ja auch wieder verschwinden. Das ist halt nicht für jetzt unmöglich.
Und es ist aber auch klar, dass die Avantgarde derer, die also da in den 60er
Jahren losmarschiert sind.
Also dass die, wenn man heute so die speziellen Feinheiten der Genderforschung
sich zum Beispiel anguckt, was die sich so alles überlegen,
dass da ein Bauer in Niederbayern nicht so richtig mitkommt und es nicht so voll seine Sache ist.
Ist irgendwie klar. Und wenn die sozusagen, also wenn jetzt eher rückständige oder periphere,
Menschen oder Teile der Gesellschaft, wenn die revoltieren gegen den sogenannten
Fortschritt, wie ich ihn definiere, ist es irgendwie auch klar.
Ob die damit Erfolg haben werden, das ist eine andere Frage und das sehe ich
eigentlich nicht unbedingt geklärt.
Aber es ist schon so, so geht es ja vielen jetzt meiner Generation und älteren
Linken in den letzten Jahren diese Depression und wie die Populisten überall
sind Populisten und es wird alles schlechter und so.
Wer weiß, vielleicht haben wir ja jetzt auch eine 18er-Revolution,
die jetzt aus der Hecke gesprungen kommt.
Ja, aber so schnell geht es dann eigentlich in der 21er, also Revolte, keine Revolution.
Also das muss man wirklich unterscheiden, denn Revolutionen sind meistens Ereignisse,
wo bestehende Systeme zusammenklappen.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Revolutionäre immer dann die Revolution machen,
sondern sowohl 1918, das hat Walter Rathner auch mal beschrieben,
es ist keine Revolution, es ist ein Zusammenbruch.
DDR 1990 war doch keine richtige Revolution.
Also nicht so mit dem König unter Schafott schieben wie in Frankreich oder richtig kämpfen,
sondern es gibt Systeme, die sich als nicht reformfähig und willig erweisen
und die irgendwann kollabieren die und dann obsiegt eben die Opposition.
Aber das ist nicht in jedem Fall eine richtige Revolution.
Und was Rebellionen oder Revolten angeht, jederzeit, ich wäre begeistert.
Ich glaube auch, wenn heute die jungen Leute, die werden immer so beschimpft,
ihr wollt gar nichts mehr, ihr seid so auf Sicherheit, ein Risiko,
keine Meinung und was man ihnen alles vorwirft.
Das kann auch sich sehr schnell ändern da glaube ich muss man immer mit Überraschungen
rechnen aber man kann sie nicht vorhersehen.
Ja, Micha, das war ein cooler Ausflug. So hatte ich mir das vorgestellt.
Hast du noch einen letzten Gedanken, den du dem Ganzen noch hinten anstellen möchtest, abzurunden?
Nee, wahrscheinlich viel zu viel. Also kein letzter Gedanke.
Okay. Na dann bedanke ich mich für den Überblick.
Ja, vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Dein tolles Buch kommt ja auch bald raus hier. Berlin, Stadt der Revolte, da haben wir das Wort.
Da ist dann alles nochmal richtig akribisch zusammengetragen worden.
Ja, da habe ich versucht, auch Dinge, die nicht so bekannt sind,
also wenn Rebellen aus Ost- und Westberlin mal zusammengearbeitet haben,
die zu recherchieren und das zu beschreiben.
Und vor allen Dingen, ich bin ja alter Berliner, ist das ein wichtiger Teil
der Berliner Geschichte. Berlin wäre nicht so interessant und attraktiv,
wenn es hier nicht immer wieder Revolten gegeben hätte, sonst wären wir in München.
Obwohl da gab es 1918 ja auch eine Retro-Revolte. Aber also das ist, und dann von daher,
also Denkmalsetzen ist jetzt so furchtbar pathetisch, aber ich wollte schon
bestimmte Personen auch würdigen,
die mit in 16 Jahren auch mit großem Risiko losmarschiert sind und ja,
die Teil des kollektiven Gedächtnisses oder der kollektiven Erinnerung nach
Stadt, aber auch eines Landes bitte sein sollten.
Alright, danke nochmal.
Bitte, bitte.
Danke fürs Zuhören hier bei CAE. Ich sage Tschüss, bis bald.